So, Pogu, wobei das Emoji deaktiviert ist.
Geht ja gar nicht mehr.
Haben wir noch Pogu?
Dann muss man kurz Emoji checken.
Pogu gibt's nicht mehr.
Deaktiviert weil alle poch emotes entfernt wurden
Subscribern nice od ich höre gerade die subscription notification funktionieren wieder nice
Dankeschön Für. Den sub julie genetics ja poch ist Tatsächlich entfernt
Rejected von ffz und von
Guck mal wie es bei der twitch tv aussieht wahrscheinlich auch Rejected
Ne da können wir poch wieder enden so
So ich interessiere mich überhaupt nicht Für. Irgendwelche politischen sachen um emotes ich will Einfach meine emotes haben
So nice poch so funktioniert wieder alles
Hey leute ich war ein bisschen wenig in letzter zeit sowohl videos technisch als auch live stream technisch ich weiß ich bin grad sind
sinnloser weise all school mmos grinden weil es bock macht so aber
Ich hatte gestern schon vor einem video aufzunehmen was zu de ein video über mal wieder über das
Leidigthema dedos da gibt es nämlich ein paar interessante neugierden microsoft hat ein report rausgebracht über
Das Letzte Jahr was sie in azure so für dedos attakten mitbekommen haben beziehungsweise
Sie vereiteln konnten ich mein microsoft möchte natürlich werbung für sich selbst machen
Und da waren richtig
Riesen dinger dabei da wollte ich was drüber machen habe ich gestern angefangen aufzunehmen beziehungsweise ich war angefangen was aufzuschreiben ich angefangen aufzunehmen
Ich habe angefangen was aufzuschreiben habe ich nebenbei mmo technisch eingeloggt
Und habe gesehen ach guck mal pvp bg und so alles schon ab bin gejohnt ich habe morgens um 10 Uhr angefangen mit gestern 22 ins bett ich habe zwölf stunden am strecken
Kreisel kreit gemacht wirtschäm ich habe das auch gemerkt dass ich keine 22 mal bin oder so wird richtig der arsch weh getan am abend
Vom ganzen sitzen ich habe auch zum ersten mal seit langer zeit mal wieder am rechner
Mittag gegessen und abend gegessen war ich ja normalerweise nicht mehr
Moin
Bist du eigentlich twitsch partner geworden ich habe einen antrag gestellt auf das aufgenommen zu werden in das twitsch partner program
Und dann wurde ich twitsch partner
Prinzip sowie jeder andere auch
Der um uns sagt max hatte ein meeting am freitag da hat ein angeblicher bei ihm ist man sich immer nicht
Seht er gebadet auch gerne mit seinen chat messages bevor ich jetzt bevor ich jetzt weil jetzt ich er hat schon öfters
Gebetet also das ist immer mit vorsicht zu genießen was er so schreibt
Max hatte ein meeting am freitag da hat ein angeblicher def gesagt dass mit lara well nutzen sagt ihr dass das nichts mir
Was
Also entweder es ist früher weit
Also max hatte ein meeting am freitag ok da hat
Ihm ein angeblicher entwickler gesagt dass mit lara well nutzen sagt ihr dass das hat mir nichts gesagt
Ach so er wollte wissen ob der lara well was sagt würde gerne mal wissen was du darüber
Darüber sagt er hat so geredet als ob der laden das nächste erst ab ja das ist ja normal
Also darüber zu reden dass der nächste laden das nächste google microsoft sap netflix was auch immer was auch immer so die branche passt
Ja wird ist ja normal das machen sie alle
Ich glaube ich war noch bei keinem unternehmen was nicht intern die ganze zeit erzählt hat dass sie absolut genial die die besten und
Eigentlich das krasseste unternehmen auf der welt sind das ist das ist glaube ich standard
Ja kannst du ja poste ruhig ist ok das ist normal und
Auch können wir uns gleich angucken
Ja
Also wie gesagt dass das ist normal ob man lara well jetzt kennen muss
Weiß ich nicht also ich kenn es das ist ein php framewars
Ich habe damit mal falls ich noch irgendjemand hat zufälligerweise mal jemand auf meinem damaligen battlefield 4 server gespielt
Dort gab es eine stats page
Weil er sowas nicht anbietet angeboten hat ich habe eine stats page
Für meinen battlefield 4 server damals gemacht
Wo jeder so ein eigenes profil haben konnte mit seinem spielernamen
Das war mit lara well aber das war lara well
0.5 oder sowas das ist uralt
Ja aber
Wir sagts was also ich finde man kann das durchaus gehört haben
Großartig ahnung davon haben weiß ich nicht php ist jetzt ja mittlerweile nicht mehr so dass das must must have must know
ding schlechthin also
Ob man das unbedingt kennen muss weiß ich nicht. Eher nicht
Ich meine breite übersicht haben und alles mal ein bisschen gehört haben ist immer gut
Aber jetzt also das wäre jetzt für mich jetzt kein kriterium gewesen dich zu nehmen oder nicht zu nehmen wenn du davon nichts gehört hast es sei denn es sei denn
Der laden setzt ausschließlich lara well ein
Und wollen jemand der da auf hohem niveau schon direkt einsteigen kann dann ist es natürlich blöd jemand einzustellen der von dem eigentlichen framework
Worauf der ganze laden basiert noch nichts gehört hat
Aber ansonsten dieses gelaber dass der laden das nächste sap google microsoft netflix
Meta ist es ja was auch immer und google ist es ja auch nicht was es ja eigentlich jetzt
Alphabet und ihr wisst was ich meine ist das ist normal
Und es finde ich genauso lächerlich wie du dass die alle immer so übertrieben selbst ansicht haben
Die 0815 eck klitsche um die ecke ist halt nicht das nächste netflix oder das nächste microsoft
Und wird es wahrscheinlich auch nie werden
Ja
Witzig witzig wenn ich dann immer wenn die wenn die stellenanzeigen haben oder der meinung sind irgendwelche
Krassen also brain teaser tests und alles mögliche machen zu müssen das kann vielleicht microsoft und google machen die die wollen ja auch wirklich die besten und die besten wollen zu ihnen
Aber aus 69 zuschauer huge gachi buss aber
Ist bei denen ja gar nicht der fall so du hast die die seite von den eingeschaltes wordpress ja das wundert mich nicht
Halbe millionen für ein projekt ist ja gar nichts
500.000 euro budget für je nachdem je nachdem ist gar nichts
Halbe millionen für ein projekt ist ja gar nichts 500.000 euro budget für je nachdem je nachdem ist gar nichts
Muss ich überlegen allein schon wenn du ein team hast mit zehn entwicklern können die
Für für eine halbe millionen ein halbes jahr halbes jahr bis jahr daran arbeiten dann ist das geld weg
also
budget budget von einer halben millionen sind gar nichts für ein etwas umfangreicheres IT projekt
Also je nachdem in welchen Sphären die da schweben also wenn sie das nächste SAP sein wollen auf jeden fall schon mal nicht
Ok leute also was gibt es sonst neues ich versuche nachher das video fertig aufzunehmen zu der ganzen DDoS thematik
Wer das nicht gesehen hat ich zeige ich versuche ich zeige euch das gerade mal
Ich habe es hier gar nicht ich glaube heise hat eine news post dazu gemacht die DDoS
nicht DDoS die DDoS
Ja und dann gibt es ein original news artikel von microsoft genau
Da waren echt paar interessante sachen drin und zum beispiel wusstet ihr
Dass das internet in andorra haben hat das jemand von euch mitgekriegt das muss ich mal internet andorra
Wusstet ihr dass das internet in andorra weg war weil irgendein minecraft minecraft turnier gededost wurde
Das war mir neu war mir neu bis gestern habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen
Die ganze minecraft zoomer wieder hier am start
Hab ich mir nicht genauer angeguckt warum ja keine ahnung
Durch DDoS angriffe auf ein internet provider in andorra wurden mehrere minecraft spieler aus einem turnier gekägelt
Die wollten irgendwelche leute die am turnier teilgenommen haben nicht dass sie am turnier teilnehmen haben sie gededost und das hat den
Hat den service provider in andorra lahm gelegt und damit dementsprechend wohl auch
Komplette internet sachen in andorra
Vermutet wird dass der angreifer den einzigen service provider blatt attackiert ja gut das ist andorra wieviel einwohner hat andorra 450
Okay 77.000 habe ich aber die richtung stimmte nicht
Ja
Das ist so bescheuert
Da hat es dann auch die oma in andorra abgekriegt die mal kurz im internet irgendwie mit ihrem enkel chatten wollte oder so
Weil irgendwelche leute minecraft sachen gededost habe schon schon heftig zumindest ist es interessant was in diesem microsoft
DDoS report drinne steht also das erste was mich in was ich
Bemerkenswert fand wo ich nicht mit gerechnet habe dass ich den angriffe mittlerweile hauptsächlich gegen games richten
Also zumindest da wo es am meisten angriffe gab und am härtesten zugestanden waren tatsächlich games
Also geht an von blizzards spiel im titanfall haben wir alle mitgekriegt
Tarkov dead by daylight final fantasy 14 wurde auch gededost
Ja, irgendwelche
VPN woib dings anbieter und sonst was
Finde ich eigentlich ganz interessant
Das zu lesen ist nicht so spannend aber so ein paar punkte da draus deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich mach da auch mal ein video drüber
Natürlich ist dieser ganze artikel werbung von microsoft unterm strich weil es geht darum dass microsoft
So geil ist und mit ihre azure didos protection die welt rettet
Was auch sonst was anderes hätten wir glaube ich jetzt von microsoft nicht erwartet
Zum glück stand im artikel noch mal drin das zwischen frankreich und speil liegt
Ja das liegt in den purinen irgendwo glaube ich ne andorra so auf den berg obendrauf
Ich wohne hier in andorra also laut laut twitter andorra guck mal mal
maps
Ja
Ach da
hier hier
Hat das nicht mal smusa gescrollt google maps das ist ja eklig
Warum scroll google maps so beschissen was ist hier so beschissen
Was ist hier los liegt es daran dass es dass die erkennen dass ich nicht im chrome bin oder was
Leute seit wann
Nee guck mal hier ist hier scrolls smooth bei mir nicht
Gebetet die wollen mal wieder
browser ausschließen hier
Anzeige ist raus
Und ich kann euch noch mal was zeigen
Pass mal auf pass mal auf pass mal auf das ist richtig krass auf youtube ich weiß gar nicht was mir den abgeht
Hier kanalmitglied war so super
Ja guck mal ich so mal kurz ran
Guckt euch mal
Ja muss man mal
Ne hier sehen die emotes auch kacke aus woran liegt das denn
Hä
Bei mir skalieren die emotes im firefox nicht richtig aber im chrome schon und hier skalieren sie auch nicht richtig hä
Verstehe ich jetzt nicht
Hä hier ist es umgedreht hier skalieren die emotes im firefox nicht richtig
Was ist denn mit google kaputt
Guck mal also bei mir ist es normalerweise immer umgedreht die emotes skalieren im chrome richtig aber im firefox nicht und hier skalieren sie richtig im firefox aber im chrome
Was warum
Ihr seht die emotes sind deutlich schärfer als da
Okay, jetzt ist es umgedreht
Die emotes sind deutlich schärfer als da okay die logik muss ich nicht verstehen oder
Aber es ist es ist schon mal merkwürdig warum skalieren die emotes überhaupt unterschiedlich in den browsers
Warum sind sie nicht einfach überall scharf man so schwer ist es jetzt ja auch nicht
Und das ordentlich zu machen also keine ahnung naja
Ah ja so ist sonst ist es leute ist sonst irgendwas spannendes passiert die woche
Sonst irgendwas spannendes passiert
Sind das best resides so die nämlich man wie das eine och intentional
Es ist auch im
Russen
Peppier
Er schwer, also black
33 och sensibe eil weiterverkaufen
Kidal這種 neun ziel mir seit gestern Abend das 24 die doch okay
Ja, auf ihmidamente
Thema CSS Magic, ich will es jetzt nicht zu weit ausweiten, weil das hier im Stream die
Leute sonst zu sehr verschreckt.
Ihr könnt euch doch noch dran erinnern an das Autocomplete Form, was wir letzten Samstag
oder so programmiert haben.
Ich habe eine Idee, wie wir die Abfragen noch viel viel schneller machen können, das müssen
wir demnächst ausprobieren.
Meine SQL Abfragen waren nämlich ziemlich low IQ, die waren nicht gut gemacht.
Wenn ich die sinnvoller mache, dann sollten wir noch deutlich schneller abfragen als irgendwie
40 Millisekunden.
Da sollten wir runter auf unter 10 Millisekunden kommen.
LinusTechTips hat Datenverlust, hat er wirklich oder ist das wieder so ein G-Bait Video?
Der ist mir nämlich immer ein bisschen zu entspannt in seinen Hilfen, wir haben einen
unternehmensbedrohenden Datenverlust-Videos, der hat ja schon ein paar Videos dieser Art
gehabt und der erscheint mir immer ein wenig zu entspannt dafür, als dass es doch so schlimm
ist, wie sie das Video darstellen.
Du meinst das da?
Naja, wenn ihr wollt, können wir das gucken.
Aber ich sollte mir irgendjemand geschrieben haben, ich sollte mir diesen Clip angucken.
Okay, wir lassen mal die Mario Kart Musik dabei laufen.
Angel does it again.
Wolle, danke für den Sub.
Lass mich raten, er stirbt jetzt sinnlos.
Achso, das ist der Sonnenuntergang, der ist in der falschen Richtung, oder was?
Achso, okay, da hätte ich jetzt...
Ich hab den ja nicht zuhörlich, gar nicht drauf gekommen.
Wobei ist es nicht abhängig davon, wo auf der Welt man ist?
Ist es nicht sogar ein bisschen davon abhängig, wo auf der Welt man ist?
Also bei uns ist es im Westen, glaube ich.
Also irgendwo im Westen, aber ist es nicht ein bisschen davon abhängig?
Achso, exzellent Fallfeld-Content.
Ja, aber ich glaube es variiert trotzdem ein bisschen.
Also es ist immer die gleiche Richtung, aber es ist glaube ich ein Unterschied, ob es keine
Ahnung dann irgendwie westlich ist, nordwestlich oder südwestlich oder sonst wie.
Ich glaube das hängt schon ein bisschen davon ab, wo man auf der Erde ist.
Die Himmelsrichtungen mögen überall gleich sein, aber der Sonnenaufgang kann ja bei den
einen direkt hardcore westlich sein, bei den anderen ein bisschen nordwestlich.
Die Erde ist ja auch leicht schräg, keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube das ist das Unterschiedliche, nachdem wo man auf der Erde ist.
Wenn man jetzt natürlich auf einer flachen Erde wäre, dann wäre das wieder was anderes.
Da habe ich auch letztens mit einem Video gesehen, da habe ich den Glauben an die Menschheit
verloren.
Das ist Wahnsinn, die sind teilweise so absolut gehirnbefreit, die Leute, das ist Wahnsinn.
Willkommen jetzt, wir fragen einfach Google, Sonnenuntergang Richtung.
So, die tägliche Veränderung des Sonnenstandes wird durch die... Okay, zwischen Nordwest
und Südwest, seht ihr das kann sich unterscheiden.
Vielleicht unterscheidet sich das auch noch Jahreszeiten, keine Ahnung.
Wo geht die Sonne auf, was, wo geht die Sonne auf Deutschland, fehlt da nicht noch ein Wort.
Die mögliche Richtung variiert also fast um 90 Grad, okay, das Wikipedia weiß Bescheid,
haha, Feifett-Content wieder.
Es hängt nicht auf der Position auf der Erde, sondern von der Jahreszeit ab, so wie der
geografischen Breite, doch, ist doch wichtig, wo man auf der Erde ist.
Wo der Untergang am Horizont beginnt, hängt von der Jahreszeit zu wie der geografischen
Breite ab, aha, zur Tag- und Nachtgleiche ist er auf allen Breiten fast genau im Westen.
Das ändert sich also der Punkt, wo es anfängt.
Im Dezember, Januar, Januar ging es für Mitteleid im Südwesten und im Juni, Juli, Nordwest,
das ändert sich.
Excellent.
Jett, jetzt wissen wir wieder Bescheid, alles klar.
Gibt es auch schöne Videos zu skippern, zu fast allen Videos.
Was gucken wir uns heute als erstes an, ich würde es, achso, ja, ich sollte mir das,
our data ist, der Typ ist mir immer viel, wie gesagt, der ist mir viel zu entspannt
dafür, dass ihre Daten weg sind und es ist auch einer der Gründe, warum ich die letzten
Jahre über eigentlich kaum noch gucke.
Also es gibt zwei Arten von Videos, die ich nicht mag, das eine ist so Videos aus der
Mücke in den Elefant gemacht, was sie auch teilweise gerne hier haben oder halt Sachen,
die ich will nicht sagen gestellt, aber überdramatisiert sind, aber gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal.
Warum?
Wisst ihr was ich nicht verstehe?
Warum, also wenn, jetzt mal ganz ernsthaft, wenn quasi meine Existenz des Unternehmens
an einem Fileserver hängt, so wie das ja immer dargestellt wird in diesen Videos, sollte
ich da nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise insofern Vorkehrungen treffen, dass mich
der Ausfall dieses Fileservers nicht mein ganzes Geld kostet, wäre das nicht sinnvoll
irgendwie.
Also zum Beispiel würde ich mir dreimal überlegen, ob ich einen eigenen Fileserver zusammenbaue,
wenn mein Unternehmen davon abhängt, da würde ich mir zum Beispiel überlegen, ob ich mir
nicht ein fertiges Storage System kaufe, was dann über, was dann in irgendeiner Kiste
angebunden wird, wo ich Samba drüber machen kann oder Windows Stairs oder aber die bisschen
besseren Storage Systeme können ja mittlerweile alle schon selbst, gucken wir mal, auch heutzutage
messen wir was in Warzone Installationen, top, die Lautstärke ist ziemlich, das ist
einfach, also wenn das wirklich so ist, dann ist das einfach Unfähigkeit, also ganz ehrlich,
wenn die, wenn die, sag mal so, wenn die eigene Existenz an den Daten auf diesem Fileserver
hängt, da müsste schon echt der gesamte Kontinent quasi instant gleichzeitig abfackeln,
dass ich da irgendwelche Daten verlieren würde, also wenn man es ordentlich macht, das wird
dann nicht nur lokal gebackupt, das wird offsite backup und wahrscheinlich auch nicht nur einmal,
also wirklich Verlust sollte da eigentlich nahezu ausgeschlossen sein, was passieren
kann ist, dass der Service vielleicht mal einen halben Tag oder so nicht zur Verfügung
steht, wenn man es natürlich einfach nur auf irgendwelche lokal zusammengeschusterten
Platten schiebt und sich dann wundert, dass es kaputt geht, der Werbung ist Hetzner Werbung,
ja gut, der weiß halt was Gutes, na, na, egal.
Leute, hat jemand schon ausprobiert, ob Ausrufezeichen Hetzner, ob mein Gutscheincode noch funktioniert
in letzter Zeit, den Raid bringt ja nicht zwangsläufig was, Alter, mach dich so ein Krach, oh,
also Raid ist eine gute Sache, wenn du willst, dass das Service bestehen bleibt, also wenn
du, also Raid ist gut dafür, wenn du willst, dass du bei einem Ausfall nicht den, dass
deine Leute noch weiter arbeiten können, wenn eine Platte kaputt geht, so, das Dumme an
Raid ist, dass es sagen wir mal so halbwegs synchron ist, also sprich, wenn du aus Versehen
was löscht auf dem einen, also wenn du auf den Windows-Share gehst und jetzt entfernen
drückst und löscht, dann ist es halt weg, oder wenn du Malware hast, die dein nass verschlüsselt,
das ist dem Raid halt egal, dann könntest du was weiß ich, wenn du Glück hast, hast du
vielleicht irgendwie irgendwelche ZFS-Snapshots oder sowas, das du schnell wieder rückgängig
machen kannst, ja, und wenn der Server nicht läuft, dann, ja, also Raid bringt schon was,
hat schon so einen Sinn, was Raid 5, 6, 10 funktioniert seit 2000, warum sollte das seit
2014 nicht mehr funktionieren, was hat sich denn an der grundlegenden Logik von Raid geändert,
was seit 2014 nicht mehr funktionieren soll, natürlich funktioniert Raid 5 und 6 2014
immer noch, kannst 6 Platten nehmen oder 5 Platten oder was auch immer an Raid 6 machen,
das ist kein Ding, warum sollte das nicht mehr funktionieren, und Raid 10 ist ja eigentlich
nur Zusammenfassung aus zwei Raid-Levels, das funktioniert immer noch, unter Windows,
keine Ahnung, aber bei Linux gibt es da verschiedene Varianten, du kannst es mit ZFS machen, du
kannst es mit MD-Raid machen, du kannst glaube ich sogar, ich glaube sogar, dass LVM mittlerweile
eine Mirror-Geschichte eingebaut hat, naja, gucken wir mal weiter.
So, in the early days I managed the infrastructure and since then I've had some help from both
outside sources and other members of the writing team.
We all have different strengths, but what we all have in common is that we have other jobs
to do, meaning that it's never really been clear who exactly is supposed to be accountable
when something slips through the cracks, and unfortunately, while obvious issues...
Das ist übrigens auch ein Grund, warum, so gerade im Banken-Business-Umfeld, da wo ich
arbeite, warum sie total auf SLAs und irgendwelche Support-Verträge stehen, nicht weil es dadurch
weniger kaputt geht, sondern weil sie im Fall der Fälle, wenn was kaputt geht, quasi den
Schwarzen Peter jemand anderem zuschieben können, die können einfach sagen, ja, das
Storage-System ist kaputt gegangen, wo eigentlich haben wir hier verfügbarkeit 9999999999 eingekauft
und es ist trotzdem kaputt gegangen, wir sind nicht schuld, der Storage-Hersteller ist schuld,
es ist erstaunlich, wie oft das zieht, letztendlich müsste man eigentlich sagen, ja gut, aber
du hast den doch ausgesucht, du bist trotzdem verantwortlich, macht man aber anscheinend
nicht.
Und deswegen sind SLAs und Bussiness-Sachen total beliebt, ja, natürlich geht es dann
auch letztendlich darum, dass du Schadensersatz fordern kannst und sonst was, aber ich muss
euch mal ehrlich sagen, zumindest in dem Umfeld, also bei der Bank, wo ich arbeite, ich habe
natürlich mit der Rechtsabteilung jetzt auch nicht tagtäglich was zu tun, also keine Ahnung,
mir ist nicht bekannt, dass wir jemals erfolgreich Schadensersatz bekommen haben, wenn einer
was kaputt gemacht hat oder wenn eine SLAs nicht richtig eingehalten hat.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir es nie versucht haben oder ob wir nie gewonnen haben, keine Ahnung,
wir haben nie, also nie, dass ich mitbekommen habe, was rausgekriegt.
Das ist halt das Problem, wenn man nur irgendwelche Turnschuh-Admin-Bastler hat, das ist schön
und gut, ich spreche denen nicht das Knowhow oder den Skill oder sonst was ab, aber manchmal
ist es tatsächlich gut, wenn man jemand hat, der in einem gewissen Bereich schon Erfahrung
hat, auch schon gesehen hat, was ist, wenn es in die Hose geht und einfach weiß, was
er macht und kein Bastler für alles ist.
Egal, gucken wir mal, ah, das sind Iron-Wolf-Platten habe ich auch.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn mein Business Serious Data Storage Needs hatte, würde ich tatsächlich
wahrscheinlich mir irgendein fertiges Storage System kaufen.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen teurer, aber ist halt die Frage, mit was bezahlst du es
ja?
Jetzt haltest du es vor oder nachher?
Ja, gerade für so Kram wie ESX, da brauchst du das ja auch, da kannst du ja selbst nicht
wirklich großartig was machen, geschweige denn da irgendwie durchblicken, ja, für ESX,
was wir beispielsweise auch regelmäßig benutzen, ich habe gerade den Tab offen, ist der Oracle
Support, wobei man sagen muss, der Oracle Support ist nur mäßig nützlich, genauso
wie der Microsoft Support, also Leute, eine Support-Anfrage bei Oracle und Microsoft läuft
in der Regel gleich ab, du machst dann ein Ticket auf, ich muss es zum Glück nie machen,
ja, aber ich kriege das mit, wenn unser Support oder irgendwelcher Ticket aufmacht, du machst
bei Oracle oder Microsoft machst du ein Support-Ticket auf, da schreibst du dann zum Beispiel rein,
ich muss irgendein Beispiel, was nicht allzu fern ist, von der Realität ausdenken, zum
Beispiel schreibst du Azure Files NFS Performance ist viel langsamer als erwartet und auch langsamer
als bei ihnen in den Dokumenten drinne steht, so, dann antwortet sofort irgendeiner da drauf
auf dieses Ticket, warum, Chad, warum antwortet immer instant einer drauf, ohne dass es was
Hilfreiches ist, also meistens bekommt man als erstes so eine Antwort auf sein Ticket,
so nach dem Motto, bitte Analyse-Tool laufen lassen oder bitte genaue Firmware-Versionen
angeben oder es fehlen noch irgendwelche Nummern oder sonst was in der Richtung, also es gibt
immer instant eine Antwort drauf oder dass es weitergeleitet wird an irgendwas, warum
ist das so, das ist ganz einfach, weil die bezahlt werden für Reaktionszeiten, die werden
genau, die werden bezahlt für Reaktionszeiten, bei so Reaktionszeiten geht es in der Regel
nicht der Realität entsprechend darum, dass geholfen wird sinnvoll, sondern einfach nur,
dass reagiert wird, auch eines meiner Kritikpunkte, die ich generell an vielen so Business-Dingern
habe, die sind oftmals nicht daran interessiert, dass die eigentlich Probleme behoben werden,
sondern nur, dass irgendwelche messbaren Dinge passieren, die oftmals gar nicht zur Lösung
beitragen, zum Beispiel Reaktionszeiten in Tickets, Reaktionszeiten in Tickets ist nicht
wirklich aussagekräftig, wenn das eigentliche Problem erst ein halbes Jahr später gelöst
wird, gut, es antwortet bei Microsoft-Orgel immer instant irgendein Typ drauf, mit irgendeinem
Schwachsinn, den man nicht haben will, dann wird das weitergeleitet an was auch immer irgendwie
das jeweilige zuständige Team, und dann kommt immer, und das ist wirklich, ich sag mal 99%
der Zeit, schreibt jemand von Microsoft oder von Oracle, aber bei Microsoft hab ichs erst
letztens vor ein paar Tagen wieder gesehen, der schreibt das Problem, was du hast, schreibt
der nochmal in eigenen Worten in das Ticket rein, also wenn du schreibst, wir haben festgestellt,
dass NFS-Zugriff viel zu hohe Latenzen hat und langsam ist in das Ticket, und dann antwortet
er dir, ihr Problem scheint es zu sein, dass der Zugriff auf NFS langsam ist, haben sie
sich schon einmal überlegt, dass der Zugriff über NFS vielleicht zu langsam sein könnte,
so was in der Richtung kommt dann als Antwort rein, und natürlich, das schreiben die dann
über irgendwie eine halbe Seite lang, das ist immer richtig viel Text, aber im Prinzip
ist es quasi das, was du in das Ticket geschrieben hast, nochmal, und unten drunter steht dann,
wenn diese Antwort hilfreich war, bitte Ticket schließen.
So, und dann musst du, und dann musst du reinschreiben, mein Microsoft Logo, ne, das hat irgendeiner
hier im Chat gebaut, und dann musst du in das Ticket reinschreiben, nein, dass ihr Schwachsinn
was ihr schreibt, das wissen wir doch schon alles, jetzt kümmert euch mal ordentlich
drum, ja, und dann passiert meistens was, fühlt man sich da nicht verarscht, ja schon, aber
so ist das halt, wenn man für SLAs bezahlt und nicht für die Lösung letztendlich.
Das ist professionell side-shinden, genau, ja so läuft das, aber bei manchen Sachen ist
das sinnvoll, ja, gerade beim ESX-Support, beim VMware-Support, habe ich das bei euch
schon bei uns auch schon öfters mitgekriegt, dass es tatsächlich sinnvoll ist, da was zu
haben, und auch bei unserem Dell Storage-System war es auch schon teilweise sinnvoll, übrigens
da habe ich mal ein Video gemacht, wen Wartungsarbeiten am Storage interessieren, kann sich mal dieses
Video angucken, da hatten wir noch ein IBM Storage, wo das Firmware-Update ziemlich in
die Hose gegangen ist, ja, aber nichtsdestotrotz, so ein fertiges Storage-System zu kaufen,
wenn man da irgendwie petabyteweise Daten hat, ist gar nicht so blöd, könnt, also wenn mein
Unternehmen davon abhängt, wie bei Linus, dann würde ich mir das echt überlegen, genau
das Video, ja, das Video, wo sie einen USB-Stick in den Fahrstuhl geworfen haben, korrekt,
so, gucken wir mal, fertig, was, aha, by the way, by the way, an der Stelle auch nochmal
angemerkt, ZFS ist eine supergeile Technik, also wirklich Massive Hi-IQ-Technik, aber,
was du benutzt, wenn man keine Ahnung davon hat, ist ziemlich sicher Payne's Champ, auf
Dauer, das ist auch der Grund, warum ich NFS wieder abgeschafft habe bei mir daheim, weil
es zu overkill und zu komplex war für meine Anwendungszwecke, klar kannst du sagen, du
setzt das einmal auf und dann funktioniert's, aber die Sache ist halt die, was ist, wenn
man wirklich was kaputt ist, ja, was ist, wenn der beim Resilvern oder so, wie das heißt
bei NFS, wenn das Ding irgendwie abkackt, oder was machst du wirklich, wenn die Weißdown
ist, wie tauschst du das dann richtig aus, wie machst du einen Snapshot wieder zurück
und sonst was, das ist gar nicht so easy, es sieht halt cool auf den ersten Blick aus,
weil NFS wahnsinnig leise Features hat, du brauchst aber halt Ahnung davon und du brauchst
am besten auch Ahnung, wer sich täglich damit auseinandersetzt, dass du's noch weißt, wenn
es denn dann soweit ist, deswegen hab ich's bei mir wieder abgeschafft, egal, gucken wir
jetzt mal fertig.
Das
Rebuilden, ha, wisst ihr, was das Problem ist, das ist auch so ne Sache bei nem Raid,
du merkst oftmals, ob's richtig kaputt ist erst beim Rebuilden, warum, naja, je nachdem,
wie das Raid-System aufgebaut ist, wird ja das, was fehlt, aus Daten restored, die über
die anderen Platten verteilt sind, das heißt, ob die anderen Platten alle hundertprozentig
funktionieren, merkst du erst bei nem Rebuild, weil du nur bei nem Rebuild Sektor für Sektor
von jeder anderen Platte quasi den Kram wiederrecovern musst, deswegen geht's bei nem Rebuild oftmals
erst richtig kaputt, das sind so Sachen, das muss einem alles klar sein, als hättest,
ich hab das Video nicht gesehen, aber ich predikte einfach mal, dass sowas jetzt kommt,
weil es eines der klassischen Fehler schlechthin ist, ja, und außerdem bei hundert Platten
ist die Chance, dass was kaputt geht, relativ hoch, ja, wahrscheinlich von, wahrscheinlich
so, ja gut, guck mal, es ist ein Merkel-Tree ist da am Start, das bei ZFS ist halt der Vorteil,
du merkst das, dass das passiert, die Fehler hast du trotzdem noch, aber du merkst das
halt, dank Checksum und ziggedöns, dass das Probleme macht, bei anderen Filesystems hast
du dann das Ding, ok, du willst drauf zugreifen und ist halt nicht mehr möglich oder nicht
das, was du haben willst.
After booting back up from a power loss, ZFS pools and most other RAID or RAID-like storage
arrays should do something called a scrub or a resync, which in the case of ZFS means
that every block of data gets checked to ensure that there are no errors, and if there are
any errors, these errors are automatically fixed with the parity data that is stored
in the array.
Da hast du schon mit das Problem, hast du schon mal refs benutzt, in Bezug auf was?
Vue.js refs, das brauchst du in Vue 3, also falls es um Vue.js geht, refs ist quasi der
neue Reactive-Way in Vue 3-Dinger zu machen, oder, hä, ich weiß nicht, was du meinst,
Hydrolyzer, dankeschön für den Sub, Leute, übrigens hier die ganzen Subs, huge, massive,
hab ich überhaupt nicht gesehen, Wolle hat auch subscribt, komplett übersehen, ganz
ehrlich, ganz, ganz im Ernst, wenn wirklich mein Unternehmen, und deswegen glaub ich ihnen,
das immer nur zur Hälfte, wenn wirklich mein Unternehmen von der Existenz dieses Filesorbers
abhängt, das kann ich kaum glauben, dass man dann in solche Fallen tappt.
Vor allem ist die Chance, vor allem ist die Chance, wenn man da irgendwie, was weiß ich,
hunderte von Festplatten drinne hat, relativ groß, da muss man einfach nur nachgucken,
wie hoch ist der durchschnittliche, also wie hoch ist die durchschnittliche Fehlerrate
einer Festplatte, kann man beim Hersteller nachgucken, und dann guckste einfach mal nach,
wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit bei 100 Platten, dass das passiert, und da kommste
wahrscheinlich drauf, dass die im Durchschnitt irgendwie, was weiß ich, alle zwei Wochen
eine Platte kaputt gehen müsste oder so, übrigens, ihr müsst jetzt leider mal unterbrechen,
übrigens, das ist so ein typischer Fall von, Raid ist nicht immer besser, stellt euch
mal vor, der hätte einfach 100 Platten zusammengehängt, was wäre im schlimmsten Fall passiert?
Also er hätte 100 Platten genommen und hätte jetzt 5 Platten kaputt gehabt, er hätte,
was weiß ich, einen großen Win-Aus-Ordner da drauf gemacht, aber unter der Haube immer
noch just a bunch of disks oder wie man irgendwie sagt, was wäre im schlimmsten Fall passiert?
Die Daten, die auf diesen 5 Platten wären, waren, wären weg, aber der Rest wäre immer
noch da, wohingegen mit ihrem Raidkonstrukt, wenn das Raid failt, ist alles weg.
Das sind alles so Dinge, die man beachten muss, und das ist tatsächlich nicht easy,
und nicht von irgendwie, wir frickeln mal ein bisschen nebenbei, hobbytechnisch damit
rum, sinnvoll konzeptionell umgesetzt, da ist, manchmal ist es tatsächlich ganz sinnvoll,
ich sag nicht, dass ich es besser könnte, ich sag nur, dass ich mittlerweile weiß, wann
man sich da jemand holen soll, der wirklich Ahnung hat.
Ja, das muss, das ist an sich nicht schlimm, die haben ja auch viele Platten, also muss
man mal im Vergleich gucken, dass ab und zu mal irgendwie was failt, ist ja normal, schwer
zu sagen, ich kann jetzt schlecht einschätzen, ob das viel oder wenig ist, weil wenn man
zum Beispiel mal seine Netzwerk-Interface-Statistiken anguckt, dann wird man sehen, es gibt immer
mal Errors, die da drauf sind und nix passiert, das ist nix wildes erstmal.
No, it's not nice, that means that both the original and new petabyte projects, old
and new vault have suffered non-recoverable data loss, so now what do we do, in regards
to the correct...
Wir machen erstmal ein Video drüber, wo wir angeblich zwingend den Filesauber verbrauchen,
wie gesagt, ich sag nicht, dass es fake ist oder so, aber es ist wahrscheinlich nur drei
Viertel der Wahrheit, was man da immer sieht.
The
original
Ein neuer, ordentlich konfigurierter 1.2-Pedabyte-Server mit shiny-new-20TB-Drives von Seagate.
Die sind wirklich aufregend.
Diese Sachen sind fast wie shiny-new-20TB-Drives.
Lttstore.com
Und wenn das komplett ist, wollen wir...
... alle Daten aus dem neuen Vault-Kloster auf diesen neuen, neuen Vault...
... neuen, neuen Vault...
... dann werden wir den neuen Vault wieder aufsetzen, damit alle Drives gut sind...
... und den Prozess wiederholen, um die alten Vault-Daten anzunehmen.
Dann können wir den alten Vault wiederformieren...
... und dann werden wir den neuen Vault wiederformieren.
Und wenn das komplett ist, wollen wir...
... alle Daten aus dem neuen Vault-Kloster auf diesen neuen, neuen Vault...
... neuen, neuen Vault...
... dann werden wir den neuen Vault wiederformieren, damit alle Drives gut sind...
... und den Prozess wiederholen, um die alten Vault-Daten anzunehmen.
Dann können wir den alten Vault wiederformieren...
... dann werden wir den neuen Vault wiederformieren, umds para den neuen Data erstellen...
Dann werden wir den neuen Vault wiederformieren, umds para den neuen Data erstellen...
Wenn alles gut zusammen thiebt und glucosevelte Garrote von Powerloss lendig sind, hätte dieses ganze Problem...
... wahrscheinlich nie sein dürfen.
Wenn wir einmal breastINGING diese Daten haben würden wir einfach wieder von derouthestapulten...
der scheiß ist halt teuer ja ach
man könnte ich denke es ist mission critical das hat er doch am anfang
erzählt mal ganz davon abgesehen es gibt ja noch theoretisch andere
möglichkeiten ja also wenn man das wirklich in solchen in solchen um in
solchem umfang machen will vielleicht kann man sich irgendwo auch
colocation technisch ein mieten und da einen server hinstellen auf dem man
mir oder oder wie auch immer ja aber dass das scheiß geld kostet logisch
er hat nicht gesagt dass die dinger mission critical sind aber er hat das
ganz stark so so formuliert gesagt da der fileserver wo alle unsere video
daten drauf sind so nachdem er mit videos quasi sein geld verdient gut
weiß ich nicht wie viel als anteilmäßig ist mittlerweile also im
prinzip war das ding eigentlich komplett und überflüssig oder wie was
er jetzt abgeraucht ist also im prinzip komplett bin ist eigentlich egal ob es
kaputt ist oder nicht also entweder ist es super wichtig oder nicht und dann
hätte man gebetet ja was hier ist dann auf ok ja die machen bestimmt
mittlerweile so viele video so viel auch mit irgendwie produktion für andere
leute und so aber das ist interessant guck mal das finde ich finde ich
interessant nice video sponsorship merchandize guck mal guck mal die
sponsoring im video und die und merchandize ist die hälfte das richtig
richtig nicht übel youtube adsens ist dann quasi noch ein
drittel und da restet andere kram interessant ja ich habe einen pengen danke für den sub
so was youtube silver dislike button award die dislike sind ihr weg ich habe
sie zwar noch wegen dem add-on aber wie genau die sind man weiß es nicht
so was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an call of duty level cap
jibayden ja das muss sein leute level cap jibayden wir müssen uns einmalig im
sonntag stream level cap jibayden lassen liegt mittlerweile bin ich mir bei
allen möglichen leaks gar nicht mehr so sicher ob das alles wirklich liegt
auf rate verlassen ok da muss jetzt was zu sagen chat also weder noch auf rate
kannst du dich insofern nicht verlassen dass wenn du selbst aus versehen was
löscht dann ist es ja komplett weg also du musst eigentlich beides machen wobei
du nicht wirklich er klauen in offsite cloud backupen muss sondern du kannst
einfach über usb noch eine zweite platte dran oder was auch immer xte platte dran
hängen auf die du einmal nachts er klauen erst jüngst oder sonst was das
kannst du machen rate ist nur gut dafür dass du keinen service ausfall hast also
sprich wenn du sagen wir mal einen fileserver hast und möchtest dass der
wirklich rund um die uhr verfügbar ist auch wenn meine platte kaputt geht dann
machst du rate dass es eben nicht passiert
ansonsten müsstest du halt irgendwie kurz kurz die sachen vom backup kopieren
oder sowas ja aber wovor rate halt nicht schützt ist wenn du aus versehen was
löscht oder wenn du ein verschlüsselung strojaner hast oder was auch immer in
dieser richtung das rate weiß das ja nicht das rate schreibt das auf alle
platten drunter wenn es eine schreib und schreibanfrage bekommt das heißt das
bringt dir nichts du musst das du musst das backupen am besten und am
billigsten erste mal auf irgendeine externe usb platte oder sowas kostet
wirklich viel und ist unabhängig von einem rate kannst du theoretisch sogar
ausschalten dann machst einmal nachts an machst ein backup über erst so man so
habe ich ja bei mir auch mittlerweile
multitier man kann die sachen immer verbessern aber das wichtigste ist dass
man überhaupt einen backup hat guck mal man sieht sie irgendwie home server
enjoyer ich habe doch irgendwo ein bild von meinem server wo die wo die usb
platte oben drauf steht
irgendwo ja ja guck da 10 terabyte usb platte steht da einfach obendrauf
fertig abteilen von usb festplatte und da wird dann erst irgendwo drauf nachts
easy
man kann das natürlich man könnte das noch deutlich schöner machen mit
quasi so einem automatischen rotieren da hätte ich jetzt zum beispiel in
verschlüsselung strojaner und ich würde es nicht merken bis das nächste backup
läuft dann ist es dann halt gesüngt es wäre natürlich noch besser das so zu
machen dass du sagst hey wir haben wir machen sieben tage backup dann einmal im
monat und dann rotieren wir das wie auch immer gibt es ja verschiedene lösungen
für aber das wichtigste dass man erst mal macht es kann auch kacke gemacht
sein erst mal ja einfach blindes erst und einmal nachts vom server auf eine
usb platte es ist alles definitiv viel viel besser als gar kein backup zu haben
weiß ich nicht keine ahnung
qnap kein schimmer wallpaper ja das dashboard habe ich nur für das
video gemacht borg backup habe ich auch eine weile benutzt
das problem an borg backup für mich war also dass es ein super super produkt für
hacker mans dass ich jedes mal wenn ich was gebraucht habe aus dem backup
erst mal nicht wusste wie man es bedient weil ich so selten benutzt habe
aber an sich ist das richtig nice
ich muss mal ein bonbon lutschen
so wir lassen uns jetzt mal von der feldkampf schieben
was ist nam stolz ach er wieder er wieder das kann man es nachher auch noch angucken
ja der macht immer nice nice witz weeps out nam weeps out so schauen wir uns jetzt
mal ein wir lassen uns mal eine runde level kapitän ja das würde mich nicht
wundern weil kaldera und der was ist das aktuelle wengard ich blicke da schon
gar immer durch war so ein refresh kam ja nicht wirklich gut an information
emerged from a report by bloomberg earlier in the week detailing this next iteration of the smash
hit battle royale game the bloomberg article listed warzone 2 alongside the next three call of duty
releases all the way up to 2023 the focus of the article was about call of duty releasing on both
xbox and playstation consoles for the next couple of years so maybe ja würde mich auch fast
wundern was supposed to be the main subject whether this mention was intentional or not it does
indicate a rough idea of activision's plans for the franchise warzone 2 will apparently present
players with a completely fresh start a clean slate if you will ditching the games past content
and mechanics in favor of something entirely new this narrative has been further corroborated by
industry insider tom henderson official details are scarce right now but we could assume raven
software will continue to lead warzone 2 development with help from different support studios raven soft
sind es nicht die dies quasi irgendwie seit sie es übernommen haben permanent in warzone verkacken
somit unsichtbaren skins und und dinge an die nicht laden und sowas dass ich raven soft ist die
ganze zeit eigentlich verkacken around the world it's also rumored that warzone 2 will ship
exclusively on next gen consoles but it is believed that this is dependent on hardware availability
though when we go beyond 2023's release schedule the format for call of duty releases is less clear
we're not sure if the new owners at microsoft are going to want call of duty launching on the
playstation platform anymore werden sie wollen ich gehe davon aus dass call of duty auch weiterhin
auf der playstation rauskommt weil muss ich das ist ja im prinzip so eine reine business
entscheidung wenn man sich anguckt wie viel kohle das bringt und wie viel verkäufer das macht auf
the playstation lohnt es sich dann auf diese verkäufe zu verzichten für die vorteile die man
durch irgendwelche exklusiven sachen hätte und ich denke mal dass das zumindest kurzfristig
erstmal nein ist dass das nicht bedeutet dass das exklusiv sein wird was ich mir vorstellen
könnte ist genau so was was captain peng gerade schreibt dass es irgendwie eine woche früher
vielleicht auf der xbox kommt oder sowas erst mal in die nächste konzolen generation kommt ja das
ist ja gar nicht absehbar die eigentlich die playstation 5 ist ja relativ neu das heißt das
heißt vorweg fünf jahre bis die nächste kommt und dafür dass die playstation 5 jetzt irgendwie
gefühlt auch schon eine halbjahre oder so alt ist gibt es ja erstaunlich wenige so ist
es völlig möglich dass es eine xbox und pc exklusiv werden kann. Neue Fotos des
Star Wars 1313 Spiels, das durch den Battlefront 3 Archive-Channel auf YouTube
genannt wurde, wurden gezwungen. Star Wars 1313 wurde von LucasArts entwickelt und entstand
in seiner Prototypenphase bevor Disney das Projekt 2013 cancelt hat. Seitdem haben verschiedene
Sponsoren unterschiedliche Materialien online, Konzeptart, Gameplay-Segmente und andere Aspekte
veröffentlicht. Diese Woches Gameplay zeichnet die bekannte Boba Fett in zwei Clips. Der erste
zeigt Boba Fett durch versperrte Alleyways und Bars auf dem Planeten von Coruscant, während der
zweite Clip eine intensivte Ruhigkeit zeigt.
The Gameworld ist untextured and unfinished, but a lot of the movement mechanics and character design
is somewhat impressive. Star Wars 1313 amassed a huge following online at the time of its reveal,
which led to a lot of upset fans once the game was actually shelved. And with most Star Wars
games based around a playable Jedi character, it's sad to think how great this game could
have been if it had shifted its focus more toward the scum and villainy of Coruscant. In brighter
Star Wars news though, the legacy of the Sith expansion for the Old Republic goes live next
week and the new story trailer hints at brand new locations and characters. BioWare has confirmed
that the new locations that will appear in this expansion include the underwater facilities
on the planet of Menen, the Old Sith fortress on Elam and the R4 anomaly. This is a free
update to all subscribers of the Old Republic and is set to launch on February 15th. Developer
Crytek announced the next iteration of the Crysis franchise this week. The CEO of Crytek
shared that this new game with the working title of Crysis 4 is still in the early stages
of development, so it'll be a while as of yet. Developers on the game hope to include the
community as much as possible by inviting players to follow along with the development
through the game's social media channels. Crytek is also currently hiring people to... Crysis
1 war das beste Crysis. Change my mind....on this game and use the new teaser trailer as
a call for talent. The Crysis franchise will celebrate its 15th anniversary later this
year, so this teaser presumably ties in with that as well. Ubisoft have landed themselves
in hot water this week as Nicolas Poirre, the VP at Ubisoft's Strategic Innovations...
Ja, sie haben wieder erzählt, sie haben wieder erzählt, dass NFT das geilste ist. Das hab
ich schon gelesen, ja. Ich wette mit euch, die Ubisoft haben überhaupt keine Ahnung,
was ein NFT bzw. was da überhaupt dahinter steckt und nicht dahinter steckt. Wahrscheinlich
denken die Ubisoft-Typen tatsächlich, es hat was mit irgendwelchen In-Game Models und Bildern
zu tun.
Patronized Gamers claiming that we didn't understand their new NFT endeavour. Ubisoft announced Quartz as their NFT initiative that allowed players to buy artificially scarce digital items using cryptocurrency.
And this announcement was inevitably met with major backlash from fans and gamers. Nicolas Poirre claims the blame for this backlash is with the players and not them, stating...
Ja, ja gut. Was heißt das Problem? Die Spieler haben ja recht.
Die Players don't really get what a digital secondary market can bring to them.
Ja, ja klar. Natürlich, natürlich. Ich glaube, die hauptsächliches Problem ist, weil die
Leute sich ungefähr doch ganz gut erahnen können, was für eine Scheiße damit getrieben wird.
But they don't get it for now.
Natürlich, natürlich. Die Leute sind einfach nur zu unterbemittelt, die Generalität zu verstehen dahinter.
Ja, ja, ja.
Natürlich, natürlich. Alles klar, das ist es.
Ich meine, ich gehe davon aus, dass den meisten Leuten, die darüber flamen, tatsächlich auch nicht ganz klar ist, was ein NFT ist und dass das mit In-Game Models und Bildern eigentlich gar nichts zu tun hat.
Aber die können aus den Praktiken der Jahre davor schließen, dass es, egal was es ist, für sie wahrscheinlich nichts Gutes bedeutet.
Hier. Auf der anderen Seite hat Ubisoft auch die Erkundigung des Hyperscape-Servers eröffnet, weniger als zwei Jahre nach dem Release des Spiels.
Ah, Hyperscape Shutdown. Das war, glaube ich, das Ubisoft Battle Royale, der Ubisoft Battle Royale Versuch.
Jetzt ist es vorbei, ja.
Das Hyperscape Battle Royale Spiel versucht, das Battle Royale Landscape zu verändern, mit seinem Reveal im Jahr 2020.
Er hat sich als ein Free-To-Play-Titel gespielt, hat 100 Spieler in Squads von drei Menschen gespielt, die alle kämpfen und ein futuristisches Landscape durchführen.
Doch, als von April 28 dieses Jahr werden die Servers ausgeliefert, vermutlich wegen des Dwindling Player Counts.
Jetzt, auf der anderen Seite des Dwindling Player Counts, ist Apex Legends mit einem neuen Launch-Trailer für die Saison 12 mit dem Titel Defiance vorhanden.
Die Saison 12 wird eine neue Legend namens Maggie, eine New Zealand-basierte Legend mit...
Apex hat so krass viel Geld gemacht, John.
...alongside Maggie, die Saison 12 wird eine neue 9v9-Mode nennen, die Control, eine neue Battle Pass-Ranked-Saison und Celebratory-Giveaways geben, seit das Spiel um die selbe Zeit drei Jahre alt wird.
Der Charakter sieht aus wie irgendein Drogenabhängiger von Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof.
Nicht zu erwähnen, die Olympus-Matte sieht aus wie eine Faselift, wie in dem Launch-Trailer. Die Saison 12 fällt am 8. Februar.
Die Guerrilla Games haben neue Gameplay-Snippen von Horizon Forbidden West auf der PlayStation 5 veröffentlicht.
Es ist kein PC-Release angekündigt, oder?
Ich meine, das erste kam jetzt ja von nicht so langer Zeit auf dem PC.
Aber ich glaube, dafür wird wahrscheinlich erstmal PlayStation exklusiv bleiben.
Die Gameplay zeigt, dass die Uhtaru-Triben in Plainsong zu Hause sind und wie der Rotblatt die Lands infizieren und neue Kampf-Fotos mit Klamber-Jaws und Brüsselbacken enthalten.
Mit einem Feb. 18. Released-State sind die Erwartungen hoch für diesen liebenden Sequel.
Es wurde in der selben Blog-Post konfirmiert, dass die Game endlich Gold war, das heißt, dass sie den Launch-State erreicht hat.
Jetzt beginnt das Studio das Spiel zu prüfen und zu distribuieren.
Destiny 2-Developer Bungie hat noch mehr Details auf der nächsten Expansion des Spiels, The Witch Queen.
Microsoft zerstört Windows 11 mit Werbung
Die 5 ist jetzt auch nicht wirklich im Muss, um Windows 11 benutzen zu können.
Groove Music wurde eingestellt und auch Skype könnte praktisch eingestellt werden, ohne
dass es jemand merkt.
Microsofts Dienstestrategie hat abseits von Office und Xbox, also bei mir ist das bestimmt
5 Jahre her, versagt, da man einfach nicht das Ökosystem anbieten kann, wo man deren
Dienste bräuchte.
Also musste ein anderes Zugpferd her und leider ist es einer meiner Lieblingsprodukte
von Microsoft, der Microsoft Edge Browser.
Wegen seiner Synchronisation mit der Handy-Version, welche ich für einen integrierten Edge-Blocker
liebe, einer in meinen Augen gefühlt besseren Privatsphäre, weil ich Microsoft immerhin
mit den Daten mehr vertraue als Google, den Profilen sowie den Sammlungen, die ich fast
täglich benutze, finde ich den Edge Browser auf Chromium Basis fantastisch.
Ok, jedem was er so will.
Seit es den Edge auf Chromium gibt, bin ich ein begeisterter Edge Nutzer.
Aber während die Entwicklung sehr positiv begonnen hatte, mit einzigartigen Features
wie dem Tracking-Schutz, den Sammlungen und vertikalen Tubs, konzentrieren sich die Verbesserungen
von Edge in letzter Zeit nur auf eine Sache.
Microsoft baut immer mehr Werbung ein.
Hier ist ein Beispiel.
Ihr ändert eure Suchmaschine und stellt ein paar Einstellungen um.
Wenn man nicht explizit auf kein Interesse klickt, kommt bei jedem Edge-Start diese
Meldung wieder.
Echt?
Und schlägt euch vor, Microsoft...
Zack?
Ich hab das ewig nicht aufgehört.
Was?
Assist?
Nein.
Und jetzt?
Let's go.
Ok.
Google.
Wir googeln über DuckDuckGo.
Perfekt.
Aber wahrscheinlich habe ich irgendwann schon mal akzeptiert hier.
Microsofts empfohlene Einstellungen für Edge zu übernehmen.
Warum?
Nun, die Antwort ist ganz einfach.
Microsoft möchte hauptsächlich, dass die Standard-Suchmaschine wieder Bing wird und
nicht jede eurer...
Ja, nur Bing will kein Mensch verwenden.
Ja, das steht direkt drunter im Kleingedruckten.
Aber das ist wieder so eine dumme lästige Meldung, die ihr wegklicken müsst oder im
Bestfall für Microsoft, lest ihr sie nicht mal und klickt auf übernehmen, nur damit
sie eben verschwindet.
Schubs ist eure Suchmaschine wieder Bing.
So eine Scheiße.
Aber auch Nutzer, die bereits einen anderen Standard-Browser gewählt haben, denen legt
Microsoft nur noch Steine in den Weg.
So zeigt Windows 11 in letzter Zeit solche Meldungen als Fullscreen-Popup.
Oh nee.
Klickt ihr auf die von Microsoft empfohlene Einstellung, dann ist euer Standard-Browser
wieder Edge.
Diese Taktik gehört mir auch auf den Sack gehen.
Und wer die Suche im Windows 11 Startmenü nutzt oder aus dem Widget-Menü eine Nachrichtenmeldung
lesen möchte...
Seriously, verwendet dieses Widget-Menü irgendjemand?
Ich finde, das ist so eine ultra überflüssige Entwicklung, genauso überflüssig wie dieses
komische mit Ding hier neben rechts.
Edge-Browser weitergeleitet, egal welchen Standard-Browser ihr ausgewählt habt.
Und obwohl ich Edge nutze und auch eigentlich ein Fan davon bin, finde ich solche Dinge
aufdringlich und einfach scheiße.
Aber der Spaß hört da natürlich nicht auf.
Microsoft versucht nicht nur zunehmend mit einem höheren Bing-Traffic für mehr Werbeeinnahmen
zu sorgen, sondern hat offenbar auch viel mehr Potenzial erkannt, ordentlich Cash zu
machen.
Was sonst?
Nun gibt es beispielsweise schon eine Microsoft-Shopping-Integration.
Diese empfiehlt euch Coupons, wenn ihr auf einer Seite eines Onlineshops rumscrollt,
ähnlich wie das Honey und andere Dienste machen.
Natürlich verdient der Anbieter dieser Coupons auch eine schöne Affiliate-Provision, wenn
ihr einen von ihren Coupons benutzt.
Aber die schlimmste und an Dreistigkeit nicht zu übertreffende Integration ist die Partnerschaft
von Microsoft mit Zip, einem Anbieter für sogenannte Buy-Now-Pay-Later-Lösungen.
Bei Zahlungen im Internet.
Pay-Now-Pay-Later?
Was?
Buy-Now-Pay-Later?
Hört sich nach einem Kredit an.
Also, Buy-Now-Pay-Later, das ist bestimmt ein Kredit, aber schön für Zoomer verpackt
oder?
Zoomer-Kredit heißt nicht mehr Kredit, nett noch, danke für den Zap.
Bei Zahlungen im Internet kann euch Microsoft also vorschlagen, euren Kauf über einen Drittanbieter
in Raten aufzuteilen, weil ihr das nötige Geld nicht sofort aufbringen könnt.
Euer Browser dreht euch somit einen Kreditvertrag an.
Ja, das ist scheiße.
Und da die Problematik dieser Nullprozent-Finanzierungen vertraut ist, würde es sehr wahrscheinlich
die Finger davon lassen.
Das sind sehr oft ganz problematische Verträge, die da gerne verknüpft werden.
Sowas hat meiner Meinung nach in einem Web-Browser nichts zu tun, aber für Microsoft ist es eine
sehr lukrative Möglichkeit, seine wachsende Nutzerbasis in Edge zu Geld zu machen.
Und der Konzern zeigt auch, dass man offenbar die Dreistigkeit hat, genau das auch zu tun.
Aber das ist nur meine Meinung.
All das, also der Edge-Zwang in den Widgets, die nervigen Empfehlungen im System, sowie
die Vorschläge für die Suchmaschine, sollen die Leute von Google zu Bing bringen.
Ja, wird aber nicht, das wird aber wahrscheinlich nicht passieren.
Soll die Nutzung von Edge steigern und Edge anschließend die Suchmaschine Bing pushen.
Mehr Traffic auf Bing bedeutet mehr Relevanz im Werbemarkt und das bedeutet Anzeigen auf
Bing werden wertsicher.
Also das einzige, wofür ich Bing verwende, ist für Image of the Day für meinen Linux-Hintergrund.
Das ist alles.
Und wiederum für Microsoft selbstverständlich mehr Cash.
Und nachdem niemand Bing wirklich benutzen will, weil die Suchmaschine einfach schlecht
ist, so dreht man uns in der Zwischenzeit...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ich weiß gar nicht, ob Bing wirklich schlecht ist, die anderen funktionieren
gut genug, dass ich gar nicht den Drang danach verspüre, auf Bing zu gehen.
Ich benutze DuckDuckGo relativ oft, seit den letzten zwei Jahren schon und Google natürlich
und eigentlich habe ich überhaupt keinen Bedarf für Bing.
... und verdient etwas Geld mit Coupons.
Für einen Browser, welcher mit einem Betriebssystem mitgeliefert ist, ist sowas echt lächerlich.
Ja, ja, gehör mich mit dem Recht.
Von uns wird es noch ein Video geben, wie ihr sämtliche Werbung in Windows 11 deaktivieren
könnt.
Angefangen von den nervigen Benachrichtigungen im System bis hin zur genannten Edge-Problematik
und wie man diese eben löst.
Microsoft muss allerdings verstehen, dass dieses Verhalten von Nutzern nicht toleriert
wird, weswegen wir einen Feedback-Hub-Eintrag erstellt haben, dem ihr auf jeden Fall eure
Stimme geben solltet.
Ja, da sagt Microsoft jetzt direkt, äh, abgelehnt.
Den Link dazu unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Den Feedback-Hub, wo kommt man da jetzt raus, wenn man da drauf drückt?
Darf man das überhaupt mit Chrome aufmachen?
Ja, dann nicht.
Mein Fake-Account wurde geplockt, oh nein.
Wenn ihr Windows 10 und 11 regelmäßig benutzt, kann das Programm MS Edge Redirect verwenden,
das die Links zum Edge-Browser zu eurem ausgewählten Standard-Browser weiterleitet und sogar die
Windows-Suche zur Suchmaschine eurer Wahl weiterleiten kann.
Auch das findet ihr in der Beschreibung verlinkt.
Achtet nur darauf, dass dieses Programm konstant im Hintergrund laufen muss, um zu funktionieren,
was besonders für Laptop-Nutzer relevant bzw. auch negativ relevant sein könnte.
Negativ relevant?
Kann im Zweifelsfall auf die Akku, äh, da auf die Laufzeit gehen.
Ja.
Oder es gar nicht mit Edge anfangen.
Ich verstehe natürlich, warum Microsoft das macht.
Google ist dominant beim Browser sowie bei der Suchmaschine und Microsoft will etwas
von diesem Werbekuchen haben.
Aber ich finde, Microsoft versucht es nicht wirklich, damit sein Produkt, also Bing und
seine Dienste besser zu machen, sondern drangsaliert Nutzer, sie eben zu verwenden, obwohl sie
das offensichtlich nicht möchten.
Nein, Microsoft, ich habe nicht zufällig meine Suchmaschine tief versteckt in den Einstellungen
des Browsers geändert.
Und natürlich verstehe ich, dass man die Entwicklung eines Betriebssystems sowie eines
Browsers irgendwo finanzieren muss.
Bei Android und Google Chrome ist die Sache.
Naja, da muss man sagen, Microsoft hat Geld als Fuck.
Die haben erst letztens Activision gekauft.
Die haben einen Gewinn im Jahr, der ist irgendwie mehr als Netflix, Amazon und, äh, nicht Amazon,
sorry, äh, Netflix, Nvidia und was war es?
Netflix, Nvidia und noch irgendwas zusammen.
Und also Geldprobleme haben die wirklich schnell.
Recht offensichtlich.
Mozilla macht es über seine Stiftung und Opera sowie Brave machen das über Deals mit Suchmaschinenanbietern
und natürlich über Werbung, also jene Seiten, die man standardmäßig im Browser angepinnt
hat.
Zum Beispiel Hotels.com und so.
Microsoft will über Edge die Reichweite von Bing steigern und die langfristige Entwicklung
seines Windows-Betriebssystems damit finanzieren, denn für Windows monatlich was zu bezahlen,
das fällt niemanden ein und nachdem die PC-Neuanschaffungen immer seltener werden und Hardware deutlich
länger aktuell bleibt, verdient man mit Lizenzgebühren deutlich weniger, als man das einst gemacht
hat.
Dafür verdient man mit anderen Sachen krass viel.
Der Weg zur Steigerung des Marktanteils von Edge und auch von Bing führt über die Verbesserung
des Angebots.
Der Edge-Browser hat auch seine bisherigen Fans und Nutzer wie mich über Qualität bekommen,
dank innovativer Features und kleiner Verbesserungen und nicht per Zwang.
Denn der Zwang hat nur eine Folge, er schadet dem Image und dürfte auch Kartellbehörden
nicht wirklich egal sein.
So, das war es dann auch schon von mir und von diesem Video.
Ja, kann ich, kann ich, kann ich ihm voll ganz recht.
Opera ist doch nur ein Trojaner, der steht, also gehört auf jeden Fall irgendwelchen China-Chinesen,
ja.
Ja, die haben richtig viel Geld.
Es braucht eigentlich eine eigene neue Web-Render-Engine, so Firefox zum Beispiel.
Ist ja nicht so, als hätten wir nicht sowas, wobei es Mozilla, also was mit den Mozilla-Leuten
los ist, verstehe ich nicht, die schaffen es tatsächlich seit den letzten 5 bis, eigentlich
schon länger, 5 bis 10 Jahren ihren Browser kontinuierlich schlechter zu machen und kontinuierlich
quasi das, was Firefox ausgezeichnet hat, ja, beispielsweise die riesen Add-on-Auswahl,
die vielen Sachen, die du machen konntest mit Add-on, was nicht alles gab, so quasi
ein Browser für Technik, wie auch immer, äh, Enthusiasten zu haben, haben die ja nach
und nach ausgebaut und verschlimmbessert, guckt euch nochmal dieses Kackmenü hier an.
Weiß nicht, was mit Mozilla los ist.
Mario, danke für den Sub, IIQ-Subscription, Massive-Crazy-Lego-Bild, ok, zeig her, ich
lasse mal die Musik an, huge, so weit wäre ich auch noch gekommen, es wird schon schwierig
langsam.
Ok, das Chat, das kriegen wir auch noch alles hin.
Warum hat er dafür eigentlich seine krassen Handschuhe an?
Darf man die nicht touchen, die Lego Bricks, die Klemmbausteine?
Was gibt es, wenn es fertig ist?
Willst du die Modes etwas verkleinern?
Tactical Lego Building Handschuhe, alles klar.
Ja.
ja
und jetzt
das noch sehr genau kaputt der chat
wieder noch habe ich keine wirkliche
vorstellung was es geben soll wenn es
fertig ist
außerdem grün gelben block und noch
ein grün gelben block noch einen grünen
block grün gelben block
naja irgendwas muss es ja damit sein
das wird nicht einfach nur ein block
sein ok ah ok verstehe high IQ block
ach so ok das hätte ich gar nicht
daraus erkannt dass aha jetzt ok das
hätte ich nicht erkannt was er da
baut sein flexibler block
ein flexibler und weiter
jetzt baut er einen ring draus
da steht auch irgendwas von brick
bilder drauf auf den handschuhen das ist
dann wirklich der quasi high IQ lego
lego bilder der hat solche handschuhe noch
eins
nee nee
aus wie luftfilter ja das stimmt schon
hat quasi das rad neu erfunden ja naja
gut also massive crazy lego bild ich
meine es ist eine coole sache mit
diesen flexiblen dinger aber ob das jetzt
so massif crazy und weiß nicht
ersatzreifen
chat weiß bescheid ja ich meine es ist ein
lego reifen
teuer ist es wahrscheinlich weil so viele
teile verbrauchst ja ok naja gut so also
so so krass vom hogger im bad war
genau so krass vom hogger hauts mich
jetzt nette kostet mehr als ein
richtiger reif wahrscheinlich so teuer
wieder lego krams ist wobbel wobbel
wobbel
ziemlich ziemlich koggers das ganze
aha
ok alles klar
gut gut dass wir uns das angeguckt haben
jetzt weiß ich bescheid falls ich mal
lego reifen bauen will dann ist klar
hässli lost faith in dais ich hätte
schon aber theoretisch wenn ich bei ea
wäre hätte ich schon nach der ersten
demo wahrscheinlich felsen dais
verloren aber ok self hosting security
guide modern warfare zweier das mir
egal ok hässli lost faith in dais von
zeit mal her acht minuten kommen zu
schnell geben
das ist das ist ja oder da hat so eine
geile aussprache
explain ok er hat eigentlich auch er hat
diesmal auch keine andere machte einfach
im video drüber alles klar das gibt mir
self hosting security guide for your
home lab ok
wer ist das moment moment ist das der
typ ist das nicht der der der der der
typ wo wir uns letzten video von
angeguckt haben der irgendwie drei
proxmox server und kubernetes cluster
und sonst was hat nur um darauf im
endeffekt nichts laufen zu haben
ich erinnere mich da das war doch ein
video wo ich gesagt habe eigentlich an
sinnlosigkeit kaum zu überbieten
ok der erklärt uns heute wie mal unser
home lab sicher machen sagt man ja
people think about self hosting
services in their home lab they often
focus and only think about
schlaut genug oder bei last mile i mean
the last hop before user accesses your
server na ja im im home lab ist es
meistens so zwischen user der meinen
server exist jetzt der gibt es nicht so
viele das bin ja meistens ich oder
irgendjemand anderes der hier im haus
wohnt jetzt nicht so als müsste ich mir
nach großartig gedanken drum was hat
eigentlich für high IQ ausdrücke liegen
diese lauter geht glaube ich noch die
musik ist übrigens nicht von mir die
hört sich an wie von mir aber das ist
bei ihm video but it's also important to
know that security starts at the
foundation of your home take for
instance this diagram this most likely
makes up most things in your home whether
that be physical or virtual you'll find
that you have most of these components
ist das so ist das so ja ich habe eine
festplatte das ist richtig ja ich habe
ein handy das ist hacker bob und kogas
hat er auch guckt wobei unser kogas
definitiv besser ist als sein kogas
hier ist das so ok ok was sehen wir hier
wir sehen ein smartphone ein wifi oder
so weiß man nicht netzwerk ein firewall
ein das ist vpn axis oder ist das vpn
axis ja warum ist ein intern auch noch
mal eine cloud ist das vp soll das hier
vpn axis sein telefon internet quasi
eingang vpn was auch immer internes
netzwerk noch mal in die server und dann
noch ja ok das ist quasi so eine art dmz
und das hier hinter ich vermute mal so
was möchte er uns damit sagen
ok zeigt mal her was das net blocker
today we're going to discuss some great
practices in architecture for self
hosting services within your home
ja dann in to individual systems
hardware configuration application
hosting considerations network
configuration and segmentation reverse
proxies certificates and two factor
firewall configuration die data
rakete fliegt internet security
settings and will even lean into
external protection from a provider
like cloud flair this will cover
everything from the line flair all the
way down to the hardware was hat ich
überleg gerade was genau hat laut
flair mit meinem home lab zu tun
mir fällt da nicht so viel ein wenn ich
ehrlich bin ich verwende cloud in
cloud flair dns für meine zertifikate
ok aber ja und speaking of art
ok wir können skippen erstmal werbung
drinne so was the best way protecting
yourself while self hosting don't just
don't do it seriously you don't pay
fat time aber das ist dumm wenn man das
nicht macht weil dann muss man seine
sachen über die china chinesen cloud
laufen lassen und ich habe so meine
zweifel dass die weniger in meinem
interesse handeln als ich selbst
exposing yourself to the internet also
nein das ist ja gerade der witz dabei
wenn man eine wenn man sachen daheim
betreibt niemand zwingt ein das dem
internet zu exposen warum warum soll ich
das überhaupt machen also sprich wenn
ich daheim irgendwas laufen habe ja von
einem fileserver bis zu einem wiki bis
zu irgendwie notizen und und to do calendar
und was auch immer ich muss das doch
nicht ins internet exposen warum tun die
leute immer so teilweise in solchen
videos sobald ich daheim irgendwie den
raspberry pie hinstelle ist er im
internet ist er doch gar nicht ist doch
schwachsinn webseiten selber hausen ja
das würde ich nicht machen aber es geht
ja hier um es geht ja hier irgendwie um
sachen die man für daheim braucht meine
externe webseite hauste ich bestimmt nicht
daheim und die easy way to mitigate
that is to just don't do it at all i
know that's not why you're here or what
you want to hear so let's move on to
the next best step also hat sich
mühe gegeben mit seinem tief tiefen
unschärfer und hintergrund in mind that
i'm not a security professional i'm just
some random person on the internet giving you advice exposing your services
through a self-proclaimed piano is
dafür bin ich ja da jetzt
probably the next best way of exposing
your services without doing it publicly
this will create a secure tunnel from
the outside of your network to the
inside of your network
okay das sollte wirklich ein vpn sein
and limit what the vpn can access this is
a quick win and a secure way of exposing
your services but only the people with
vpn access will be able to access them
sin und zweck der sache
still want to expose some services publicly
so let's talk about public options
ja das würde ich da da gebe ich ihm in
sofern recht würde ich auch nicht machen
also Sachen die ich wirklich von
jedem public erreichbar haben will die
würde ich nie bei mir daheim hosten und
schon gar nicht intern irgendwo bei mir
daheim also in irgendeinem internen netz
ausrufezeichen hetzer in chat für meinen
ne ne stimmt da geht ja dieses ja gar
nicht mehr ich muss ich muss mit denen
auch mal besprechen was wir dieses jahr
noch machen
als wir dieses jahr was machen
still has its own set of concerns but it
does negate a lot of the risk of hosting
it at home that's because if that
machine gets compromised they haven't
compromised a machine on your local
network it comes by fat machine in the
public cloud but again that's not why
we're here today we're here to self
host services on our own network but
aber aber das ergibt es ergibt
allein schon aus einem ganz anderen sinn
keinen sinn public services bei sich
daheim zu hosten meine anbindung daheim
ist einfach viel zu kacke um da sinnvoll
was hosten zu können
wie soll ich sinnvoll was bei mir daheim
hosten mit meinem kacke na ja so kacke
ist er gar nicht ein voter von 400 down 40
ab wobei die 40 ab hier entscheidend in
dem fall
directly from their home this is where
okay wo geht's weiter
most people think of the last mile
felby dankeschön jetzt für den sub
but security starts at a much deeper
level so rather than focus on this last
hop right here we're going to zoom in and
focus on the server that's running your
services
you typically don't think of the
hardware when you're hosting
applications in in the cloud you really
don't have to
but since we're hosting in our own
personal cloud we do need to consider
this the biggest takeaway here
is to be sure that the hardware that
your application is running on
are patched with the latest firmware
this includes firmware
ja ja ja insofern gebe ich ihm recht
spätestens seit spekta und meltdown und
sowas
ist das tatsächlich nicht verkehrt
drauf zu achten dass man die aktuellste
aber noch mal ja früher hätte ich
gesagt es eigentlich wurscht aber ja
warum nicht ja für devices like the
motherboard
hard drives network adapters and any
other device
habt ihr ernst habt ihr habt ihr schon
jemals die firmware einer festplatte
gepatcht ich noch nie
ich habe legit noch nie ein firmware
update meiner festplatte meine ssd
gemacht noch nie
und mir war bis jetzt habe ich gar
nicht dran gedacht dass man das machen
müsste
habe ich noch nie gemacht keine ahnung
klar ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen
dass es updates gibt
bei über manche ssd für manche ssd
controller oder so
dass es geht dass ich habe da noch nie
dran gedacht das zu machen ja
stimmt bei den allerersten oder einer
der ersten samsung ssd gab es mal
probleme
ja stimmt
das ist das ist das ist das ist das ist
auch ein firmware für ein router oder
network device in deinem umfeld
aber wir werden in die konfiguration
hier ein bisschen
und jetzt müssen wir entscheiden ob wir
unsere operativen system virtualisieren
oder sie nur mit Metall aussteigen
wirklich es gibt keine falschen Antworten
hier es geht wirklich um wie du deine
Infrastruktur beherrschen willst
das beste ist so einfach wie möglich
das wird ihm jetzt vielleicht nicht
gefallen
weil wie gesagt er hatte irgendwie 20 20
vms und irgendwie zwei kubernetes
cluster und sonst was für sich daheim
wo ich bis heute nicht verstanden habe
warum er die eigentlich hat
aber letztendlich die die beste antwort
für sachen daheim ist so simpel wie
möglich weil ihr beschäftigt euch nicht
jeden tag mit der infrastruktur bei euch
daheim ihr wollt ja eigentlich dass es
möglichst vor sich hin läuft und
funktioniert das heißt wenn ihr mal was
machen müsst umso einfacher es ist umso
schneller seid ihr auch wieder fertig
und macht nicht im zweifelsverordnung
irgendwas kaputt also natürlich kann man
sich irgendwie eine wilde mischung aus
wo wir vor uns das video von ninos mit
dem storage server gesehen haben klar
kann man sich eine wilde mischung aus 10
festplatten mit zfs und verschlüsselung
und hast du nicht gesehen und allem
gedöns basteln wenn es aber auch einfach
eine externe festplatte mit usb tut auf
die man regelmäßig kopiert ist das
für den heimbereich mit sicherheit die
sinnvollere variante weil es die
einfachere variante ist und man noch am
ehesten durchblickt wenn mal was nicht
funktioniert hast du bei dir vms oder
container ich habe beides ich habe eine vm
laufen für home assistant mit ein paar
usb sachen durchgereicht und ich habe
container laufen für wiki für für das
für das wiki und
andere sachen aber kannst du das video
von mir angucken weil ich habe ups ich
habe doch letztens auch ein video zu
diesem thema gemacht hier guckt mal da
habe ich doch gezeigt home server
enjoyer habe ich doch gezeigt was ich
hier am start habe ich habe den doku wiki
sachen für fernsehaufnahmen mein home
assistant das ist die vm übersicht meiner
kameras octoprint für den 3d drucker
unify dashboard monitoring in password
manager uralt grafana was ich mal für
nutze quellgrund vor allem adblocker
analytics für ein paar website nextcloud
die ich nicht ab kann aber die ich immer
noch im einsatz habe ohne hardware
verwaltung die ich kaum verwende ja das
sind alles container der home assistant
ist allerdings vm giga chat am start
ja das ist richtig ein weiterer punkt
dafür warum man es so wenig komplex wie
möglich machen will damit man hier noch
den überblick behält und dass man nicht
irgendwie muss ich da halt regelmäßig
drum kümmern und da hat man habe ich
daheim kein bock drauf das soll einfach
funktionieren wir benutzen immer nur und
da sind wir uns ja einig wir benutzen
immer nur sonst nix immer ubuntu server
die home assistant vor allem als hi ja
dass das image was man sich von denen
darunter laden kann das fix und fertige
windows wer macht denn so was arch by
the way ist das einzig wahre
ja ja in der theorie in der theorie
wie
das
Naja regelmäßig regelmäßig pullen wäre auch bei container nicht
Schlecht aber
Da bin ich zu faul für solange der kram funktioniert sage ich ganz ehrlich
Und nachdem ich meinen kram ja wirklich nur intern betreibe und nichts von außen erreichbar ist sehe ich da ist auch weniger ein problem
Zwerg cringer sagt übrigens
Neisser name bei der zwerg cringer sagt bei mir in der arbeit ist windows standard
Ihr macht dort netz zeug wir in der java abteil sind einzigen die mit linux arbeiten ja beste zum ein mal mittlerweile
dotnet core unter linux besser entwickeln kann als unter windows finde ich
Ich benutze ja auch zum größten teil dort net für die meisten sachen die ich mache und das mache ich exklusiv unter linux
Ja watchtower ist nicht so einfach du kannst habe ich auch installiert habe ich auch installiert funktioniert zum größten teil aber
Es kommt immer mal wieder vor gerade bei doku wiki die sich da nicht mit rum bekleckern
Dass das nach einem update auf einmal dann nicht mal verfügbar ist und dann erst mal gucken muss was sache ist
Ja deswegen ist auch wichtig dass man nicht immer latest nimmt bei den containern sondern in den stable tag aber gucken wir mal weiter
Die docker container d oder pod man oder any other you want to be sure that this service is patched and up-to-date
Also, I recommend using containers from official sources
This can be a challenge, but you'll want to be sure that you're getting containers from the maintainer
Das ist richtig da hat er recht da hat er recht
Ja, and after you've chosen your container
You'll want to check to see if they support a minimal image when that's built on something like Alpine
The reason you want to do this is for a couple of reasons first of all you get a smaller container
Next this container now has less attack surface
Das das ist in der theorie der hat der hat schon komplett recht aber wie gesagt gerade im heimbereich
Das wo richtig worauf ich den haupt vorkurs legen würde ist möglichst einfache
Maintainability habe es richtig ausgesprochen
Weil dann macht man es nämlich auch es hat keinen sinn wenn ich das alles super krass komplex secure aufbauen
Aber dann kein bock mehr hab drum mich drum zu kümmern dann ist ein bisschen einfacher aber ich mache regelmäßig
Updates und kümmere mich regelmäßig drum auf jeden fall sinnvoller
Und dementsprechend kann es durchaus sinnvoll sein man nimmt einfach ein standard ubuntu image für seine container
Wenn man ab und zu vielleicht sich auch mal reinkonnecten will und was nachgucken als irgendwie in den alpine linux oder sowas
Ich würde halt immer das offizielle image nehmen und gut ist
Und das mit diesem attack surface ja
In der theorie natürlich alles was du da drauf hast kann potenziell probleme machen aber du
Bist ja bei einem container prinzipiell schon mal ein bisschen sicherer unterwegs
Erstens wegen der sandbox drumherum das ist aber nicht die hauptsächliche punkt aber es ist ja erst mal nur das exposed was du
Du explizit auch freischaltest also wenn du einfach container startest
Ohne ports weiter zu leiten an dem container jetzt erst mal nicht so wirklich viel passieren
Du musst ja erst mal an ports weiter leiten dass du überhaupt auf die anwendung da drauf kommst und die anwendung hat halt nun mal gewisse abhängigkeiten
also
Er hat schon recht ich weiß jetzt nicht ob man da so großen fokus daheim drauf legen muss mit
Less dependencies have less to patch or the possibility of vulnerabilities. So if you choose a container that has more services
That's more to patch more with the possibility. Ich nehme das offizielle image schon fertig ist
After you've selected your container you'll also want to take into consideration
The tags that you use now, this is kind of a double edged sword
Most people want to pin their containers to latest to ensure they have the latest container and then they'll use
Ich würde nie ich würde nie latest nehmen ich würde immer irgendwie sowas hier vorne entweder stable ist auch so ich würde nach möglichkeit sowas hier
Nehmen ich würde 1 2 0 als tag nehmen das bedeutet nämlich ich bekomme updates
Security updates für 1 2 also ich bekomme wenn ich den tag 1 2 0 nehme bekomme ich 1 2 0 2 als patch aber nicht
1 2 1 oder oder 2
Das würde ich machen also habe ich das bei meinen container auch gemacht
Also, ich würde ein versions tag nehmen aber dann inklusive den
Patches also ich würde den übergeordneten versions tag nehmen
Das Problem aber auf der Arbeit auch gerade
Keep in mind that latest may not have gone through the same testing in rigor that a tagged version of an image has
This convention is really going to be up to the container maintainer
Ja doch Doku wiki hat überhaupt keine ordentlichen tags ich weiß nicht was die so treiben
Looking at the nginx container is that if you can pin to a specific version like this one 1.2 1.5-alpine
That's a good bet or you can pin to a less specific version like 1-alpine or even 1.2 1-alpine
Ja das werde ich nehmen
Das das würde ich wahrscheinlich nehmen da kriege ich nämlich die patches für 1 2 1 und es ist sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich
Das was bei einem update kaputt geht innerhalb des gleichen releases
Wanted a high level a specificity you could actually pin to this digest here, but that's going a little far
But this does add some maintenance over time and you'll need to work this into your maintenance rotation
But the takeaway here is that the higher level
Ich habe bei seinem setup eh das gefühl er macht nichts anderes
als maintenance rotation den ganzen tag means that it's more easily reproduced in the future
Und nun zum Networking
Es gibt zwei Sektionen zum Networking die sehr wichtig sind
Interne und externe Networking
Starten wir mit interne Networking
Es ist ein Muss um deine Networksegmentung zu machen, wenn du auf Selbstausgabe-Applikationen planst
Die Idee hinter Networksegmentation ist, dass du deine Networksegmentung in die Mehrwertsegmentung verbreitest
Du hast deine Networksegmentung in mehrere Sektionen oder Subnetten
Jedes so wie sein eigenes
Also wenn man wirklich externe Services daheim hosten will ist das natürlich sinnvoll
Wie gesagt ich würde prinzipiell keine externe Services bei mir daheim hosten
Was mit der Internetanbindung in Deutschland meistens auch gar nicht sinnvoll möglich ist
Das lässt dich die Flucht der Networke kontrollieren
Zwischen beiden Networks und sogar internen basierend auf einer Networksegmentung
Das kann nicht nur die Leistung verbessern
Aber auch die Sicherheit
Du kannst das durch Subnetting oder VLANs machen
Und das lässt dich die Geräte, die du vertraut hast, separat halten
Oh, Osimodell, Leute
Transportschicht und
Bei euch ist das noch nicht so lange her
Sicherungsschicht und Transportschicht, kann das sein?
Ich krieg's aus dem Kopf nicht mal genau zusammen
Also das müsste dann Layer 3 und 4 sein
Keine Ahnung, scheiß drauf, Osimodell, Alter
Also das ist ja in der Regel das, wo Firewalls aktiv sind
Subnetting insofern, dass sie über die Firewall gehen müssen erstmal ist natürlich sinnvoll
Weil du von einem Netz nicht ins andere kommst
Aber ansonsten haben Subnets und VLANs mit Firewalls erstmal nicht so viel zu tun
Ideen aus Rakete
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt
Da hat er natürlich Recht
Da hat er natürlich Recht, deswegen hat man normalerweise, wenn man sowas macht, eine DMZ vorne, bevor es dann intern
Aber das ist auch der Grund, warum ich sowas schlicht und ergreifend einfach nicht intern hosten würde
Oh ja, das stimmt, da hab ich ihm Recht, das ist das China-Chinesen-Gekommene-WLAN daneben
Das ist tatsächlich sinnvoll an der Stelle
Die ganzen IoT-Geschichten, die sollten unbedingt in ein eigenes WLAN, WLAN und Firewall-Regel dazwischen
Unbedingt, ja
Da muss ich halt auch mal überlegen
Mittlerweile gibt es so viele smarte Geräte daheim
Von der Küchenmaschine bis zum Wäschetrockner, von irgendwelchen Lichtschaltern bis Lampen an der Decke
Und dass die Geräte smart sind in dem Sinn, ist eigentlich nicht das Problem
Sind das Z-Wave, Zink-Bi-Geräte oder sonst was, ist das kein Ding, das stimmt schon, was der Chat gerade schreibt
Problematisch sind IoT-Geräte, die einen vollwertigen Netzwerksdeck haben, also IP, TCP und alles mögliche
Die halt über WLAN ins Internet gehen
Weil wir denken mal an SolarWinds zum Beispiel, das war eine Business, also eine mega teure Business-Enterprise-Lösung
Und was ist bei SolarWinds, SolarWinds, wie auch immer man das ausspricht, kann sich noch einer dran erinnern, was da passiert ist
Dort wurde über den offiziellen Update-Server eine manipulierte Software angeboten, die die Leute dann installiert haben
Also sprich, es wurde eine Malware-verseuchte Variante installiert
Das ist eine super teuer bezahlte Business-Enterprise-Lösung
Jetzt könnt ihr euch mal überlegen, was passieren kann und wenn man im Internet ein bisschen rumguckt, sind ja auch schon öfters mal Sachen passiert in dieser Richtung
Wenn zum Beispiel IoT-Geräte sich Firmware-Updates ziehen, die dann halt nicht nur IoTen, sondern auch Teil von irgendeinem Botnetz neuerdings sind oder was auch immer treiben
Und das kann natürlich bei WLAN-Geräten passieren
Deswegen flashe ich auch alle, das ist einer der Gründe
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, es muss ja nicht immer böswillig sein, dass irgendwelche Hackermans das übernommen haben
Viele IoT-Geräte gehen über irgendwelche China-Chinesen-Server und was die treiben, da will ich gar nicht wissen
Das heißt, ich flashe den Kram immer und die stehen bei mir auch in einem abgeschottenen WLAN drinne, die können eigentlich nirgendswo hin
Schon gar nicht ins Internet raus
Und ich glaube, niemand möchte, dass der Lichtschalter, den man hat, demnächst beteiligt ist an einem DDoS-Angriff
So bescheuert das klingt im Jahr 2022, ist das durchaus eine äußerst realistische Möglichkeit, dass euer Lichtschalter beim nächsten DDoS-Botnetz-Angriff mitmacht
Lichtschalter goes brrr, genau
Brrt
Skrr, skrrra, papapapapa, macht er dann
Paints-Chub
Ja, das ist richtig, das ist richtig
Wie nennt man dieses Firewall-Modell hier eigentlich? Also es ist auf jeden Fall keine dreieinige Firewall mehr und es ist auch keine klassische 2-Layer-DMZ
Was ist denn das? Fällt mir nichts dazu ein gerade, was das für ein Firewall-Modell ist
Hydra-Modell
Da hat er Recht, da hat er Recht, ja
Das ist auch richtig, das ist auch durchaus richtig, das ist halt krasser Overkill für die meisten Leute daheim
Aber ja, ich würde wenn ich, sagen wir mal noch, für den Fall der Fälle, dass ich wirklich, ich hab doch hier das Video von mir
Zeig das mal kurz, ich hab doch da ein Bild von meinem Netzwerk drinne
Für den Fall der Fälle, dass ich mal wirklich auf die Idee kommen würde, sagen wir mal, ich würde mir eine Webseite machen, angenommen ich möchte mich irgendwo bewerben
Und würde irgendwie so eine Portfolio-Webseite machen oder so und die hoste ich selbst
Was ich nicht machen würde, aber nur mal für den Fall der Fälle
Hier hab ich ein Bildchen von meinem Netzwerk, was ich dann machen würde ist folgendes
Ich nehme beispielsweise einen Raspberry Pi und würde den hier dran anschließen
Quasi das Netz zwischen Fritzbox und meinem Router Schrägstrich Firewall
Hier würde dann ein Raspberry Pi dran kommen und der bekommt dann halt einen Nginx drauf oder was auch immer, irgendein Reverse-Proxy
Und dann würde ich wahrscheinlich meine Web-Anwendung dahinter laufen lassen
Wenn es einfach nur eine Webseite ist, wird die direkt vom Nginx ausgeliefert ohne irgendwie Reverse-Proxy oder sonst was
Der Vorteil ist, da kann ich auch gleich Zertifikatsmanagement und sonst was drüber machen, alles gut
So würde ich es wahrscheinlich benutzen, ja
Aber ansonsten, wenn ich irgendwie sowas wie Nextcloud hätte, es gibt ja Leute, die wollen Nextcloud extern aufrufbar machen
Ich würde immer einen Reverse-Proxy davor stellen, der sich nicht nur um Zertifikate kümmert, sondern auch um Authentifizierung
Weil ich trau Nextcloud kein Stück
Also ich meine nicht damit, dass die was einbauen absichtlich, sondern einfach nur, dass es nicht richtig auf die Reihe kriegen
Reverse-Proxy, ja natürlich, ich benutze auch intern ein Reverse-Proxy allein schon für Zertifikatshandling
Ich habe hier für alle internen Services eine gültige Let's Encrypt Zertifikate
Und das geht nur, wenn es über ein Reverse-Proxy geht, ansonsten müsste sich jeder Dienst selbst um Zertifikate kümmern
Das ist ja unsinnig
Ups, wollte ich gar nicht abspielen, ist gar nicht mein Video
Ja und wie gesagt, ich würde Nextcloud im Leben nicht öffentlich ins Internet stellen, aber es gibt ja Leute, die wollen das
Und wenn überhaupt, dann mit VPN
Aber wenn man das wirklich wirklich will, dann nur mit einem Reverse-Proxy davor
Warum nicht, weil du da ziemlich private Daten drauf liegen hast und alles, wo du jemand die Möglichkeit gibst direkt vom Internet drauf zu connecten
Hast du halt potentiell ein Problem, auch wenn es gerade keine bekannten Sicherheitslücke gibt, aber du hast immer die Tür auf
Es gibt Sicherheitslücken, kann man es halt ausnutzen, weil der Port ist halt auf
Wenn du einen VPN dazwischen hast, dann kann keiner drauf von außen, außer du mit VPN einwahl
Und wenn du gar nichts offen hast, können die halt gar nichts machen
Sobald du den Port weiterleitest, sobald du quasi von außen auf diesen Dienst drauf kommst, ist der Dienst potentiell verwundbar, wenn es Probleme gibt
Das muss ja mal klar sein, deswegen würde ich mindestens den Reverse-Proxy davor stellen
Aber ich würde es eigentlich nach Möglichkeit nie nach außen aufmachen
Watt? Warum genau sollte ich an der Stelle einen Cloudflare Reverse-Proxy verwenden? Hä? Das ist doch schon außen quasi
Jetzt blicke ich nicht mehr durch
Ach so, jetzt weiß ich was er meint
Der meint das gleiche, wo der Preis-Champ auch drüber gelaufen ist, nur halt dann auf den Hetznerserver und nicht über
Der meint diese Basic Cloudflare DDoS-Protection, ja, das kann man machen
Naja, das stimmt nicht wirklich
Cloudflare leitet das ja einfach nur weiter, also wenn dein Service dahinter verwundbar ist, über irgendwie SQL-Injection, was auch immer, dann macht Cloudflare nichts dagegen
Heißt nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung von den Paid-Tiers bei Cloudflare
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, Cloudflare hat irgendeinen Service, der der SQL-Injection-Versuch vielleicht sogar erkennt, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht
Aber zumindest im Free-Tier ist da nichts
Achja, man sollte eine Sache noch sagen, Cloudflare kann den Traffic lesen, das muss einem auch klar sein
Der Inhalt ist nicht verschlüsselt, der Inhalt ist verschlüsselt zwischen deinem User und Cloudflare, nicht zwischen dir und dem User
Cloudflare ist quasi der Endpunkt, wenn du es so machst, wie er das macht, dass Cloudflare es weiterleitet
Du kannst diese Verbindung hier auch verschlüsselt haben zwischen Cloudflare und dir, aber Cloudflare kann da reingucken
Hier hört die SSL-Verbindung auf
Wenn du es so machst, weil hier muss ja auch das Zertifikat liegen, was ausgeliefert wird an den Client
Cloudflare kann das lesen, ja
Wie gesagt, ich kenne mich mit Cloudflare überhaupt nicht gut aus, es gibt bestimmt Möglichkeiten das anders zu machen
Aber da kannst du einige Services von Cloudflare nicht verwenden, weiß ich nicht, ich habe Cloudflare noch nie mehr als das Free-Tier verwendet
Ja, das stimmt, da kriegst du einen Capture
Dann kriegt jeder einen Capture, auch normale User
Wie bekommst du Let's Encrypt-Sorts für internes Zeug? Braucht man da nicht für eine eigene Domain?
Doch, ich habe eine eigene Domain, die zeigt auf den Cloudflare DNS, also die geht über den Cloudflare DNS
Im Prinzip wird gar nichts aufgelöst, aber der Cloudflare DNS ist dafür zuständig
Und ich habe dann intern, entweder Traffic oder Nginx, die benutzen dann die DNS-Challenge von Let's Encrypt und gehen über die Cloudflare API an den DNS von Cloudflare
Hinterlegen dort die Secrets für Let's Encrypt, Let's Encrypt macht DNS-Challenge und es funktioniert
Also die Server müssen nicht von außen erreichbar sein
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, das muss ich mir kurz angucken
Eine halbe Million Sachen die letzten 30 Tage, das ist nicht wirklich viel, also dass das jetzt in irgendeiner Art und Weise leistungstechnisch Probleme machen würde
Aber immerhin werden seine Sachen aufgerufen
Ja, das ist ja mit dem Industrielevel Homelab, genau
Der Preischamp hat ja mehr, aber der Preischamp ist Geschichte
Ich glaube der Cloudflare hatte 3 Millionen Aufrufe oder so insgesamt
Ja, das funktioniert, aber natürlich kann man einstellen, kann man blocken, das ist halt nur Absender, IP, Cloudflare und sowas
Das funktioniert
In der Home Assistant App zeige ich das gar nicht an, Home Assistant und WebRTC funktionieren nicht gescheit zusammen
Ne, nicht WebRTC, das war wieder was anderes, die Zip-App die wir hatten, ne, ne, hat mit Home Assistant überhaupt nichts zu tun
Ne, ne, auf dem Handy habe ich eine Zip-App von irgendwas Softphone oder so
Das hat mir der Chat mal empfohlen, das ist gar nicht schlecht, irgendwas mit Softphone, das ist gar nicht wie der Gram heißt
Das ist eine App, die muss man einmalig bezahlen, dass man auch Push-Notifications für Anrufe und sowas
Ne, ne, nicht Zäuber, Softphone, irgendwas, Softphone heißt das
So ein graues Logo, weiß gar nicht wie das heißt, das ist eine Zip-App, da habe ich bezahlt, dass ich Push-Notifications für Anrufe bekomme
Und dann ruft mich das Ding über Zip an und dann muss ich das abnehmen, ich sehe dann anhand der Nummer, dass es die Türklingel ist
Und dann nehme ich ab und dann bekomme ich ein Video von der Tür, ja, aber die Sache ist die, wir haben es ja im Stream ausprobiert
Ich kann die Türgegensprechanlage mit einer extra Kamera kombinieren, das funktioniert
Ich kann dann sogar mit dem Handy mit dem Typ reden, aber das habe ich nie so fertig programmiert, weil ich will gar nicht mit den Typen reden
An der Gegensprechanlage, habe ich mir nämlich überlegt, weil ich hatte bisher noch nicht einmal die Situation, dass ich unterwegs war
Jemand geklingelt hat und ich will mit dem reden, weil was soll ich denen sagen, ja hallo, sie sind gerade an meiner Klingel, aber ich bin eigentlich gar nicht da
Das ist ja schwachsinnig, aber ich bekomme den Anruf und kann den annehmen und bekomme dann ein Bild von einer Kamera angezeigt, die auf die Tür, also die auf die Tür gerichtet ist, dass ich sehe, wer vor der Tür steht
Also ich sehe dann zum Beispiel, ah guck mal, es ist DHL oder so, ja, aber ich zeige das nicht in der Home Assistant App an
Die Home Assistant App kannst du komplett vergessen für Kameras und Low Latency Video
Auch WebRTC geht nicht richtig mit der Home Assistant App, das ist ziemlicher Müll
Ja, so ist das halt
Wir haben mal ein Video dazu gemacht, Traffic mit Cloudflare, äh, Stream, müssen wir im Archiv gucken
Meine Dienste habe ich zum größten Teil bei Hetzner laufen
Ja, das würde auch funktionieren, aber ich habe gerne ein Video Feed
Aber ja, ein Bild mit einer Push Notification würde auch reichen, ja
Wobei man sagen muss, Push Notification auf Apple Geräte ist auch wieder so ein Ding
Da brauchst du irgendeine Paid App, sowas wie Push Over oder sowas
Weil Apple und Push ist, ja, Pan's Champ, wie vieles bei Apple
Wie funktioniert das genau mit der Haustür Klingel?
Oh, da haben wir auch ein Video drüber, äh, ein Stream drüber gemacht, da habe ich das erzählt, aber so ganz grob, da hängt kein Microcontroller dran
Das ist eine Klingel und ich habe auf Ebay, also das ist eine Siedletür Klingel Anlage, das ist so schwarze Magie, wie das intern alles funktioniert
Ich habe auf Ebay ein Gerät von denen gekauft, was normalerweise 500 Euro kostet oder so, so irgendwie 60 Euro
Das erkennt das Klingeln und kann es über analoges Telefon weiterleiten
Und ich habe dann ein analoges Telefon zu Deckt-Converter dran
Ich habe das doch, ich habe das auf Twitter gepostet, kann ich dir zeigen
Analoges Telefon zu Deckt-Converter
Mal gucken, ob ich das noch finde
Und dann klingeln bei mir daheim die Telefone, dort kann ich dann auch mit, also ich kann ein normales Telefon bei mir daheim gehen
Und mit dem Typ an der Tür reden, das funktioniert
Und dann habe ich ein.NET Programm, das sich per ZIP an meine Fritzbox anmeldet und erkennt, wenn das klingelt, wenn die Telefonnummer klingelt, für die Tür
Und das dann weiterleitet als extra Anruf an mein Handy
Das ist ZIP Sorcery, haben wir dafür verwendet, glaube ich, das Programm, die Library
Um das zu basteln und wenn ich an meinem Handy annehme, dann nimmt das den Stream von meiner Kamera
Und packt den zusammen mit dem VoIP Call und schickt ihn ans Handy
Das konnte man alles, es war relativ easy mit ZIP Sorcery zu machen
Sind Weiterleitungen ans Handy nicht relativ teuer?
Denn was heißt Weiterleitungen ans Handy, das ist ja keine Weiterleitung in dem Sinn
Es macht halt einfach einen Call, einen VoIP Call aufs Handy, das kostet ja nix
Das geht ja übers Internet
Das ist ja keine richtig echte, das geht ja nicht über Mobilfunk, es geht ja über die ZIP App auf dem Handy
So ich hab irgendwo auch ein Bild davon, hier guckt euch mal an
Gefährliche Katze hier
Wie wird das Bild von der Cam gehandelt?
Wir haben das im Stream zusammengebaut, ich krieg das aus dem Kopf nicht mal zusammen
Wie gesagt, wir haben ZIP Sorcery genommen, dann per RTSP den Kamerastream abgefragt
Dort den H264 encodeden Stream rausgeholt und auf der anderen Seite pipen wir den in den ZIP Call
Das war relativ, es war viel einfacher als ich gedacht habe
Hier ist auch irgendwie ein Beispiel für wie man einen Video Call macht
Es war, müssen wir mal eher Achieve, gucken wir mal Achieve
Tür
Tür, Klingel, Audio, hier das da
Da ist doch der Stream
Hier hab ich sogar mal so 5 fat paint Diagramm gemalt, da ist doch der Stream
Ja, Ancient Call
Und das ist das Programm mit dem wir jetzt getestet haben ob der Call ankommt
Es hat funktioniert und es war deutlich einfacher als ich mir das vorgestellt habe
So, ich guck mal ob ich das Bild finde, muss mal ein bisschen zurückscrollen
Ist schon ein bisschen her, aber so ewig auch noch nicht
Hab ich ein Bild vom Testaufbau gepostet
Äußerst spannend was da in der Dusche abgeht
Bild vom Testaufbau gepostet
Ich hoffe ich erkenne es beim trüberscrollen
Wo die Sachen noch hier oben an der Tür Klingel an der Wand hängen
Ach ja, by the way, mich hat irgendwann so ein China Shop angeschrieben
Ob ich nicht hierfür Werbung machen will
Und das ist das original Bild aus der Mail gewesen
Alles klar, dafür möchte ich garantiert Werbung machen
So, Bahnflame, hier, ne
Das ist die Katze auf der Treppe
Wo ist es denn? Ist das schon so lange her?
Viele haben ihn, wissen es aber nicht
Wo ist es denn? Wo habe ich es denn gepostet?
Ist das schon so lange her?
Das ist übrigens die Kamera am Hoftor
Hier
Hier, das war der Testaufbau
Wo ich ihn angeschlossen habe oben an meiner Tür Gegensprechanlage
Abenteuerlich, abenteuerlich
Das sind die zwei Drähte von der Tür Gegensprechanlage
Das ist das was ich im Keller auch habe
Ich meine mittlerweile liegt das alles unten im Keller und ich hänge nicht mehr bei mir an der Wand
Das sind die zwei Drähte von der Tür Gegensprechanlage
Die gehen in dieses offizielle Ding vom Hersteller
Was aus einem Türk klingeln einen Analog-Telefon-Anruf machen kann
Dann geht der Analog-Telefon-Anruf hier über dieses Kabel
Da, über dieses Kabel
An eine Analog-Telefon zu Deckt-Station
Und der geht dann per Deckt an die Fritzbox
Das ist relativ simpel, du brauchst zwei Geräte dafür
Der Rest der da liegt ist nur Stromversorgung bzw. Kartons auf Kartons
Damit es nicht runterfällt
Es ist simpel, das sind zwei Geräte die du dafür brauchst
Brauchst das da und das da, der Rest ist einfach nur optisch nicht so hübsch
Kein Quiz-Setup
Mittlerweile ist es natürlich nicht mehr hier dran, sondern liegt unten im Keller
Alles klar
So, jetzt müssen wir das Gerät wieder aufstecken
Und dann geht es weiter
Alles klar
So, jetzt müssen wir schnell das Video fertig gucken, dass es hier noch irgendwie
Nein, Cloudflare juckt mich nicht weiter
Cloudflare Firewall, du hast Ideen
Nein, wir brauchen keinen Intrusion Detection Prevention System
Internal Reverse Proxy
Orth Proxy
Scheiß drauf, komm, ist egal, weg damit
Ich hab genug geguckt jetzt
Es hat schon einen wahren Kern gehabt, was er gesagt hat
Das ist natürlich wieder absolut offer kill gewesen
Das Setup ist doch einfach
Du brauchst zwei Geräte, du brauchst vom Hersteller ein Gerät
Was dafür gemacht ist eben Klingel zu analogem Telefonsignal umzuwandeln
Entweder steckst du das hier direkt in deine Fritzbox und es funktioniert einfach
Wenn du das kannst, weil das Kabel nah genug dran ist
Oder du brauchst was, was analog Telefon zu Deck macht
Du brauchst das Gerät und das Gerät
Das ist ja nicht schwierig
Ich meine, guck mal, du musst ein Kabel einstecken, du musst zwei Kabel einstecken
Das war's, du musst zwei Geräte zusammenstöpseln
Oder du hast eine Klingel, die direkt zippen kann
Das geht natürlich auch
Und das Ding habe ich bei eBay gekauft, weil das kostet neu 450 Euro direkt vom Hersteller
Und bei eBay hat es irgendwie 78 oder so gekostet
Und du brauchst dafür übrigens auch keinen Elektriker bzw. Angst zu haben, dass du dir was tust
Weil die Spannung hier drauf ist maximal 30 Volt
Die Spannung hier drauf ist maximal 30 Volt
Also da passiert dir nichts
Bei allem anderen wäre ich vorsichtig
Die Bahn hat es verbockt
Okay
Zack
Ich will den Sound ausmachen
Ja, meine Damen und Herren, ich bitte einmal kurz ganz wichtig um Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Der gesamte Zug war ja vorhin bestehend aus zwei Zugteilen
Und im Original sollte unser Zugteil der hintere sein
Der dann auch nach Bremen fährt
Der vordere Zugteil
Alter, kannst du nicht erwarten, dass die Leute da folgen jetzt?
Der vordere Zugteil, die C632, der vorhin bis Hannover noch dran war
Sollte der vordere Zugteil sein, der dann auch weiter nach Hamburg fährt
Mir fällt es echt schwer, das jetzt vernünftig ohne Lachen auszudrücken
Es wurde verbockt
Wir sind jetzt hier auf dem Weg nach Hamburg
Scheiße, Alter
Das ist ja voll für'n Arsch
Ja, wir sind jetzt wirklich auf dem Weg nach Hamburg
Verkehrsleitung ist informiert, es wissen alle nötigen Stellen Bescheid
Ich warte jetzt selbst auf Information, wie es weitergeht
Meine persönliche Vermutung ist, dass wir mit diesem Zug hier bis Hamburg-Harburg fahren
Moment, Moment
Ich weiß nicht genau, wo Bremen liegt
Das ist aber ziemlich gut, wo Hamburg liegt
Mal kurz gucken
Map Bremen
Das ist doch ein ganzes Stück weg, oder?
Also, Bremen
Naja, es geht doch eigentlich
Das ist eine Stunde
Okay, okay
Ich mein, immerhin
Also, ich mein, es hätte krasser sein können, ja?
Aber du bist da locker mal 2-3 Stunden
Eher 3 Stunden, eher 3 Stunden zu spät
Wir sind jetzt hier auf der Strecke Richtung Hamburg, anstatt Richtung Bremen
Und
Noch auf Englisch, please
Wirklich angekommen sind
Auch wieder eine grobe Schätzung wird es nach 14 Uhr sein
Wie gesagt, sobald mir Informationen zugestellt werden, meine Damen und Herren, gebe ich die so umgehend weiter
Ich kann mich hier nur an dieser Stelle für die Firma entschuldigen
Also
Also, der Zugbegleiter hat mein Mitgefühl auch an der Stelle
Der kann ja dafür gar nichts
Und der versucht ja wirklich sein Bestes, das auf die Reihe zu kriegen
Der ganze Laden ist halt einfach kompletter Fail
Ich hab mich oft genug dazu ausgelassen
Geil
Oh Mann
Das ist wirklich hardcore Fail, oder?
Die Aussage fand ich auch geil
Mir fällt es echt schwer, das jetzt ohne Lachen vernünftig auszudrücken
Ja
Na ja gut
Da machst du nichts, ne?
Mach noch die Videobeschreibung auf, okay
Background
Das lese ich jetzt aber nicht
Ach hier ist die
Ernsthaft, der hat einfach die komplette Fahrt gefilmt, oder was?
Okay, da musst du schon Hardcore-Bahn-Enthusiast sein
W-
Okay
Da musst du schon Hardcore-Bahn-Enthusiast sein
Wenn du dir
Das anguckst
Bc es ja wirklich anders kann ich auf der anderen seite ist es bestimmt doch ohne scheiß ich kann es mir vorstellen
das ist bestimmt sehr beruhigend
das ist bestimmt sehr beruhigend kann man sich bestimmt wunderbar zum schlafen eingucken zum schlafen angucken
Da kann ich mir gut vorstellen
Darf er in der bahn überhaupt filmen
Warum nicht? Keine ahnung.
Doomswerb, Dankeschön für den Sub
So was gucken wir uns als nächstes an
What is Nam? Story of Twitch Anti-Vipe-Emoat
Auch den test vom staubsauger robot hat den wollte ich mir tatsächlich angucken weil ich mir immer noch überlege ob ich mir nicht
Diesen staubsauger robot da kauft wir gucken uns jetzt den test von staubsauger robot da an bin immer noch am überlegen ob ich nicht
Den staubsauger robot da kauft
Also den da
Ja zeig ja
Obstacle avoidance heißt er hat eine kamera ich will keinen staubsauger robot da mit kamera haben ist der kompatibel
Tudu ja ist er deswegen habe ich mir schon überlegt ob man ob ich ihn mir kaufe das ist der aktuell empolene
Roboter dafür
Und das ganze zu einem preis von ungefähr 500 euro was das gerät leistet schauen wir uns in den folgenden minuten
Gemeinsam an an der stelle möchte ich mich auch recht herzlich bei dreamy bedanken die haben wir nämlich ich will aber keinen
mit kamera
Solange er nur radar gedöns obendrauf hat es ja alles ok
Roboter wissen willst die geräte miteinander vergleichen möchtest dann schau unten in der video beschreibung da habe ich den link zu unserem blog
Gesetzt da findest du den saugroboter finder mit vielen vielen modellen die wir getestet haben auch noch einige mehr da kannst du alle
Gegenüber stellen und miteinander vergleichen ich würde sagen los geht's
Was ist für musik wieder
Doch da hat eine kamera
Der hat eine kamera vorne ich will keinen robot an mit kamera 29 99 da können die chinesen zugucken wie er bei mir die wohnung sauber macht er
Ob sie es wirklich können keine ahnung aber das ist auf jeden fall das potenzial dazu da
35,0 mal 9,68 zentimeter bei einem gewicht von 3,17 kilogramm
Die saugleistung beträgt 4000 paschal was in einer maximalen lautstärke von 64 decibel resultiert die akku kapazität
beträgt 5200 milliampere stunden was für eine reinigungsdauer von 150 minuten sollte reichen das volumen des staubbehälterns beträgt
400 milliliter also der grund warum ich mir das kaufen möchte vielleicht ist dass es die absaugstation dabei hat
150 dazu gibt es natürlich noch die absaugstation
Schauen wir uns jetzt mal gemeinsam die technischen daten und auch das mitgelieferte zubehör des dreamy z 10 pro anzeigen
Ich handelt es sich ja eigentlich um einen l 10 pro der jetzt eine absaugstation mit dazu bekommen hat nicht optional das ganze wird hier
nur in einem bundle verkauft und das ist auch nicht
Leute ist auch ganz einfach natürlich kannst du die in china chinesen wlan stellen oder sonst was in der rechnung klar das kannst du machen aber
Das ist wie vorhin bei der frage sachen ins internet stellen oder nicht hat das gerät gar keine kamera
Egal was du machst kannst du die kamera nicht benutzen weil es gibt keine kamera das ist das gleiche wie sachen ins internet stellen
Ja sind die dinge nicht im internet musst du dir keine gedanken machen
Was nicht da ist kann ich kaputt gehen damit kann ich probleme machen
Also wie will ich kann staubsauger roboter mit kamera ganz einfach
nachträglich hin zu zu kaufen das lieferzubehör ist wie bei dreamy typisch recht überschaubar wir haben hier lediglich eine kleine anleitung
beziehungsweise die anleitung ist recht dick das gerät nur wenn ich was in der app ausstelle
ist es die offizielle app und da weiß ich auch nicht was das macht also das beste beste ist tatsächlich
Einfach kein staubsauger roboter ohne kamera mit kamera fertig
staubsaugstation mit dabei wir sehen hier in der front die obstacle avoidance das ist eine
Ich finde das finde das toll dass man das obstacle avoidance nennt anstatt kamera
Die hindernisse im weg erkennen soll darauf komme ich aber auch gleich im nächsten thema noch zu sprechen
Ansonsten haben wir ein bumper im laser navigationsturm verbaut wir haben die spot clean tast die an aus tast und die
return to home
taste auf der rückseite sehen wir auch eine wischfunktion unter der klappe ja das hat mein aktueller auch schon aber die habe ich noch nie verwendet
habe ich gesagt ist er groß
Beim l10 pro ist ein bisschen größer da ist natürlich hier die aussparung zum absaugen nicht vorhanden dementsprechend musste das ganze hier ein bisschen
aufs volumen gehen gleich ist beim wassertank da ist er auch ein bisschen kleiner als drüben weil halt einfach hier ein bisschen was
Ero danke für den zapp wir haben hier eine aktive wischfunktion wir haben hier eine aktive wischfunktion vorhanden
Ja, brauchen wir nicht elektronisch gesteuert
Hat meiner auch brauchen wir nicht ganz ehrlich hab nie einmal verwendet bisher eingestellt werden
Und ja aber ansonsten keine vibrierende wischfunktion dementsprechend halt auch einfach nur ein lappen der hinterhergezogen wird bei
ecobox oder auch bei roborock zum beispiel haben wir mittlerweile vibrierende wischplatten dann einfach noch ein ticken gründlicher machen
Das ist also ich muss sagen ich
bezweifle zu bevorzuge vibrierende lappen
Schauen wir noch mal nach unten hier sehen wir die beiden öffnungen dass der staub behälter entleert werden kann
Die hauptrolle schwimmend gelagert wir haben sechs absturz sensoren auf der seite
Das muss bei mir auch so sein weil der fällt sonst die treppe runter
Die seitenbürste und natürlich die hauptbürste so viel zum
Roboter erst mal selbst werfen noch einen kurzen blick auf die absaugstation
Wir haben hier die absaugstation mit den zwei öffnungs stutzen an der front die ladekontakte hier die sensorik dass der roboter
Zurück zu seinem platz finden kann auf der unterseite sehen wir jetzt auch hier noch mal den schacht falls es irgendwo verstopfen sollte können
Wir das hier erkennen kann man auch aufbauen auf der rückseite haben wir auch ein kabel management so dass wir das
ladekabel ein bisschen
drum rum kürzen können die nachdem
also riesen ding
dieses auch da passt wenigstens auch ordentlich was rein
Was ich übrigens voll cringe finde sagt jetzt nicht so die qualität des videos ich weiß ich finde es immer blöd wenn leute mit du
angesprochen werden im video
Es ist jetzt nicht ein ich sag immer ihr ich sag immer ihr weil ich weiß da sitzen jetzt irgendwie 10.000 leute und gucken sich das an
Deswegen sage ich nie du ist immer ihr
Da braucht man auch einen filter ja klar
Leider das wäre natürlich cooler wenn dann im endeffekt hier sich das staub drinne
Stapeln würde dass man es einfach auslernen kann ne ne ne ne so einfach ist das nicht im prinzip ist es ja einen sauger für den sauger
also diese diese diese saugstation also saug den
staubsauger roboter leer
Halt eben die anderen dann nachkaufen bis zu 65 tage soll das ganze dann ausreichen
Ja, so lange habe ich noch nicht getestet
Beziehungsweise aufgrund der ganzen anderen saugroboter viele andere saugroboter die den staub bei mir aufsaugen
Dementsprechend ist er nicht voll so viel zu den details ich würde sagen wir kommen zur navigation
Navigation
Thema navigation ist natürlich besonders spannend weil die darüber entscheidet ob der robot auch jeden winkel bei die facebook staubsaugergruppe
zwischen der eigentlichen
Navigation wie findet sich der robot zu recht und natürlich auch der hinderniserkennung der obstacle avoidance du siehst es gerade schon im top down shot bei
Mir durch den bs bereich hat der robot ungefähr 34 minuten benötigt die navigation ist wirklich hervorragend
Er findet wunderbar hier zu recht allerdings sieht er die hindernisse nicht immer ich musste hier mal eingreifen hab das
Kleine ladekabel und auch die socken aus dem roboter wieder rausholen müssen die schuhe wurden gut erkannt die anderen beiden hindernisse nicht so gut
Das ist sehr schade ihr kennt vielleicht schon aus meinen anderen videos ich bin da so ein bisschen skeptisch was die obstacle avoidance angeht sowohl bei
Roborock als auch bei ecowax sind das nice add-ons wie auch hier allerdings ist es einfach was worauf wir uns noch nicht zu 100 prozent
Oh, was ich ein bisschen schade finde das kabel gefressen ist die navigation wirklich hervorragend erfährt wunderbar um andere hindernisse aufgesackt
stuhlbeine oder so drum herum
Daran gibt es nichts zu meckern aber ihr müsst halt eben aufpassen wenn es hindernisse sind die aufgesaugt werden können
dass man muss aber dazu sagen also dieses zimmer und und überall das ist
optimal für staubsauger robot das ist klatter boden die dinger sind alle so hoch dass es vielleicht ist es auch ein extra testzimmer von ihm was
Er nur dafür verwendet keine ahnung
Aber das ist schon optimale verhältnisse für so einen staubsauger robot
Bei mir ist beispielsweise fast überall teppich
Das ist dann auch schon mal nur mehr härter für die dinger
Ansonsten thema hindernis überwindung 2 zentimeter hat er bei mir hier im test geschafft
Das ist ein sehr guter wert siehst du auch wieder im saugroboter finder da kannst du dir die werte miteinander mal anschauen und das ganze
vergleichen
Sodass es hier nichts zu meckern gibt ansonsten wie gesagt ich wiederhole mich hat mit den navigationen wirklich sehr gut gefallen und ich würde sagen wir
Machen jetzt mit der reinigungsleistung weiter
Warum machen die immer so laut dazwischen schauen wir uns jetzt die reinigungsleistung des dreamy z10 pro an die obstacle
avoidance ist natürlich
eingeschaltet die maximale saugleistung habe ich ebenfalls angeschaltet da hat er in
maximales suction
52 gramm auf dem laminat aufgesaugt das ist ein erschreckend schlechtes ergebnis
Warum das hier so ist und warum die bürste hier nicht komplett bis zum boden gekommen ist kann ich an der stelle nicht sagen
Schlecht ein bisschen schade auch beim
Beim l10 pro damals habe ich schon festgestellt dass auf dem laminat die saugleistung mit nur
91,68 gramm auch nicht so gut war wie ich mir das wünschen würde aber dafür haben die beiden modelle auf dem teppich wirklich gut abgeliefert
der
Z10 pro hat hier in drei minuten 40 71,57 gramm aufgesaugt das ist ein gutes ergebnis kein spitzen ergebnis aber liegt
definitiv über dem durchschnitt an der stelle auch noch mal der hinweis auf unseren saugroboter finder da kannst du alle
saugleistungsergebnisse gegenüberstellen zum beispiel den l10 pro mit dem z10 pro und siehst auch da wo die unterschiede
nur ich kann das ich kann das ihr könnt das nicht
Redet nur mich an
Ich finde das es ist eine stil frage ich finde es einfach ein bisschen weird jam wenn man die leute direkt anredet im video aber
echt
geschmacksfrage
Was passiert wenn man aus versehen über das ding stolper näher war wahrscheinlich je nachdem wie man fällt man wahrscheinlich hin
ist er selber dran schuld man hört ja ein problem entdeckt und zwar bei der eckenreinigung auch hier wurde wieder die obstacle avoidance
angeschaltet das hat dafür gesorgt dass der robot nicht perfekt in die ecke reingefahren ist und hier nur ein von fünf
Maiskörnern aufgesorgt hat das ist eine symptomatik die ich auch bei
saugrobotern schon mal festgestellt hatte ist schon eine weile her wurde dort aber raus programmiert
Hier habe ich es allerdings wieder festgestellt ich hoffe oder es kann sein dass mit einem update irgendwie behoben was die videos sehen
Wo die haustür offen steht eben hätte ich und das teil den innenhof von den gewichtsaugen. Nee was zeigt man
Normalerweise kann es ja deswegen zonen in der app festlegen und das ding weiß ja anhand wo es losfährt an der basis station wo
Er ist dann fährt er normalerweise aus der zone auch nicht nicht raus
Ist mir das eben aufgefallen
von daher die reinigungsleistung ist ok wie gesagt auf dem laminat war das nicht so wie ich mir das wünschen würde auf dem teppich
Allerdings sehr gut
Nochmal kurz um auf die wischleistung zu sprechen zu kommen wir haben eine aktive wasserzufuhr bedeutet wir können hier
Die wassermenge in der app einstellen allerdings bewegt sich das tuch nicht wie wir das von dem robot
Moment ist wischte gerade
Naja
Das braucht kein mensch
Ein feuchtes nachwischen das braucht wirklich keiner mehr und nicht weniger so viel zum thema reinigungsleistung ich würde sagen wir gucken uns noch mal die
Aller diese lautstärke dazwischen ist der wahnsinn
Jetzt zum schluss noch mal einen kurzen blick in die app gesteuert wird das ganze über die me home app das ist eine sehr schöne
Sache du siehst hier direkt auf der startzeit dass auch der dreamy den
Das würde ich ja nicht verwenden ich würde das ding flaschen hier eingebunden ist oder der roborock s7 in meinem fall
Schauen wir uns aber den dreamy bot set 10 pro an über das kleine fegensymbol kannst du den robot direkt das ding wird bei mir
Ehe geflasht wir einfach das symbol sonst anklicken kommen wir hier in das hauptmenü rein du siehst hier meinen wohn s
Bereich was ist alles möglich du kannst selbstständig die räume unter ja gut die app juckt mich jetzt nicht
Abschließendes fazit zum dreamy z10 pro fällt ein wenig durchwachsen aus grundsätzlich gefällt mir der saugroboter wirklich sehr sehr gut
Wir haben eine absaugstation mit dabei wir haben die obstacle avoidance und wir haben auch eine sehr sehr gute
saugleistung auf dem teppich nichtsdestotrotz ist die saugleistung bei mir im test auf dem laminat nicht so
hervorragend gewesen
Aber an sich scheint es ganz okay zu sein wie gesagt auf dem teppich ist es aber dafür
Umso besser ich glaube ich bleibe auch ich glaube ich bleibe weiterhin bei ich renne einmal im monat schnell mit dem staubsauger durch
Ich habe ja meinen roborock s5 auch quasi in rennte geschickt da steht halt noch im wohnzimmer da aber
Lass ich nicht mehr fahren
Blitz da ab und zu mal durch zehn minuten mit dem staubsauger ist alles geputzt fertig schöne sache die obstacle in der einmal im monat das reicht
Der front ist auch schön allerdings kam es hier auch hin und wieder zu problemen dass eben die
Gegenstände die im weg rum lagen aufgesaugt wurden und ich hier noch mal nachträglich einschreiten musste
Bedeutet also für dich dass man auch weg ist das kabel auf acht geben solltest dass deine wohnung frei von hindernissen und herumliegenden
Gegenständen ist
Ich finde der preis von 530 euro ist durch du bist zurück auf manuell gegangen ja
Vor allem mit der absaugstation dabei da kosten andere produkte das stimmt preisleistungsmäßig mit der absaugstation mit der absaugstation ist das
Ding wirklich nice doch noch mal ein zwei dreihundert
illuminator danke für den sub definitiven roboter ist den du in die nähere auswahl ziehen solltest
Und an der stelle hoffe ich natürlich dass dir der test dabei auch ein wenig helfen konnte auch hier noch mal der hinweis
Auf unseren saugroboter finder alle von mir getesteten saugroboter und viele mehr sind dort eingetragen
Ok als gg jetzt müssen wir bescheid
Moin max ich würde es frech finden wenn die jetzt
2042 free to play machen würden vor nicht mal im halben jahr haben leute viel geld für das näher gut aber was sollen sie machen
Ich halte es für die wahrscheinlichste wahrscheinlichste
Richtung in die battlefield gehen wird die spielerzahlen sind mega schlecht spiel ja kaum noch einer portal ist tot
Was sollen sie machen
Ich halte das für tatsächlich sinnvoll
Dass die also die einzige fast die einzige möglichkeit das spiel zu beleben
Was sagst du dazu ja wie gesagt ist also shit shit happens ja also?
Ja nicht mal vorbestellen ich meine ich habe auch sinnlos geld ausgegeben
Außerdem lockt das ja unmengen an cheatern anachter wäre ich jetzt erstmal nicht so
würde ich erstmal nicht so das problem sehen
cheater haben die herstellung für battlefield 2042 cheats eingestellt
Kein witz ist wirklich so die haben gesagt das spiel spielt keiner mehr es lohnt sich nicht mehr da für cheats zu entwickeln
Und das ist kein das ist wirklich kein witz cheater anbieter haben das geschrieben die haben gesagt wir stellen die entwicklung
Für battlefield 2042 cheats ein und wer ein abo gekauft hat bekommt stattdessen einen warzone cheat
Ich denke mir das nicht aus das ist kein witz
Das wird das wird in ein warzone abo umgewandelt
Das spiel interessiert keinen mehr nicht, weil die anti nicht, weil die cheater hersteller
Du weißt wenn ein spiel tot ist wenn sogar die cheater hersteller sagen es lohnt sich nicht da für cheats zu entwickeln
Es ist nur ein witz
Das ist ein notch, das ist ein notch stonks was da läuft ja
Ja das ist der beste dm immer dein spiel ist so schlecht es will keiner kopieren
Noch nicht mal sicherheits kopien anfertigen wie man das ja in in in diesen kreisen nennt ja
noch nicht mal sicherheitskopien anfertigen wie man das ja in diesen kreisen nennt ja
so was haben wir sonst noch schönes zu bieten this sensor is twice as good as the rest
ah welcher sensor best door and window sensor ist vom aquara da habe ich sogar welche da
xiaomi aquara schaumier aquara habe ich welche am start hier zigbee sensoren sind das die sind
tatsächlich sehr nice ich habe so eine mischung aus sie wave und aquara sensoren für die fenster
und türen ich habe ja beides bei mir ist total übertrieben ich habe ich habe sich gerät ich
habe sie werf gerät ich habe wifi geräte ich habe noch alte 433 megahertz funk geräte ich habe
bluetooth gerät alles elektrosmok für irgendeinen der da probleme mit hat der sich einrädete
elektrosmok ist schlecht da dürfte bei mir nicht ins haus der rennt hier schreien wieder raus
gucken wir uns das mal kurz an ich will mal kurz gucken ob es wirklich um ein geht nur
sechs minuten ob es wirklich um ein aquara sensor geht 5g das habe ich ja ganz vergessen
5g strahlung ist ja auch noch am start und wir haben wir haben auch irgendwo in der nähe
also ganze ecke weiter weg aber sagen wir mal grob in der nähe sogar windkraftanlagen der
infraschall davon was meinte jeder mit der kilte ich ja auch alles ist dann ist vorbei 5g infraschall
elektrosmok bluetooth wifi 2,4 5 gigahertz wifi zigbee sie will das ist vorbei du bist
ja quasi permanent durchlöchert von elektrosmok ich lebe immer noch und ich bin auch noch geimpft
außer dass mir die antenne aus dem armen gewachsen ist es ja nichts passiert
und der bluetooth smog von der corona app der kommt ja auch noch dabei
stimmt stimmt und die ganze sonnenstrahlung und so was ja deswegen gehe ich ja auch nicht raus
ganz einfach alter dieser sensor sieht ja mal richtig old school aus mit kabel und so was
das dahin ist der aquara sensor würde ich sagen von der optik her
es gibt laura sensoren hätte ich gar nicht gedacht dass das so eher in in the wild so
zu finden ist sich bis sie mit bluetooth wifi laura laura sachen habe ich ja auch noch kommt
ja auch noch dabei das ist dann was 800 833 megahertz oder sowas 817 megahertz weiß die
frequenz irgendwas 800 noch was was sensoren deine sensoren in dem fall ist das ein einteil
das machst du an türamen und einteil das machst du an die tür und dann erkennt das gibt es dann
auch laura stürms wir haben sogar schon laura stürms gemacht und da ist dann ein magnet drinnen
und in den switch oder sowas 868 megahertz ja der erkennt dann wenn es geschlossen ist und die
tür offen und kann dann eine nachricht schicken über das jeweilige protokoll an die heim
automatisierung und sagt da fenster auf tür auf da kann man dann zum beispiel im dashboard sehen
bevor man rausgeht aha ich habe vergessen oben im bad das fenster zuzumachen es kann ja auch wenn
es erkennt dass du weg ist aus dem haus deine push notification schicken sagen max wieder umdrehen
fenster im bad oben ist noch auf oder es kann auch die heizung runter regeln wenn das fenster
auf geht und solche dinge ist eigentlich ganz praktisch das der channel von ihm ist wirklich
gut wer sich für so heim automatisierung zeug erstellt da macht finde ich persönlich die
hochwertigsten videos die es gibt in dieser richtung und er beschäftigt sich auch immer
damit und der typ übertreibt teilweise richtig krass nummer so als beispiel der hat einen
wie der hat holly der hat halloween beleuchtung und die ist ein wenig übertrieben von seinem
haus guck mal das ist die das ist die halloween beleuchtung an seinem haus es ist ein wenig
etwas over the top könnte man sagen also der der übertreibt es richtig der typ stellt euch mal
vor so sieht es am haus außen aus das ist schon das schon echt übertrieben zumindest der hat es
auch mit musik synchronisiert und sowas ja ja genau genau aber dementsprechend sieht man
ersetzt sich mit den mit der thematik auseinander und wenn der was testet habt ihr ja schon gehört
14 monate getestet dem glaube ich das wirklich wenn er was vorstellt ja ich wollte gerade sagen
man kann solche kontakt sensoren auch für viele andere dinger verwenden als für die
tür und das fenster für die gefriertur für den kühlschrank theoretisch fürs klo wenn ihr wissen
wollt wenn einer den klo deckel auf und zu macht was man normalerweise nicht wissen will aber falls
man das wissen will kann man es an den klo deckel machen oder was auch immer also kontakt sensoren
sind für viele sachen praktisch briefkasten wenn der briefkasten dafür geeignet ist muss man sagen
aus dem metallbriefkasten raus funken geht immer schlecht und die dinger anzubringen am briefkasten
je nachdem es ist auch nicht so schön fürs gartentor alles mögliche die sind sehr sehr
praktisch auch für die garagentür alles mögliche was macht man wenn man auszieht dann braucht man
noch sensoren die einen benachrichtigen falls man vergessen hat einen wenn du ausziehst machst du
die sensoren ab und selbst wenn du den sensor vergisst dein heimautomatisierungssystem ist ja
dann nicht mehr da passiert gar nichts außer dass vielleicht noch irgendwo an einer garagentür
oder so oder im gartentor irgendwie was vergessen hast du was soll da passieren ja wie ist die
reichweite das kommt auf die technik an also er hat ja am anfang vorgestellt sensoren für
sich bis sieweif bluetooth wifi lora also kann man im prinzip so sagen fangen wir mal an wifi
ist die range am schlechtesten wlan geht vielleicht keine ahnung sagt sagen wir mal wenn du glück
hast wenn du glück hast 50 meter oder vielleicht vielleicht 100 meter bis in garten wenn es halt
direkt am fenster hast so ein access point oder so sagen wir mal sagen wir mal 50 meter also
sagen wir mal so quasi vom eingang des hauses bis vielleicht in hof auf der anderen seite so
aber dann ist das ist dann auch schon wirklich limit wird mal sagen in der realität sogar noch
eine ganze ecke kürzer also innerhalb des hauses geht's aber sonst ist vorbei also wifi ist von
von von der entfernt da ist auch bluetooth dabei die bluetooth ist noch schlechter ich sehe es ja
gerade patrick dankeschön 31 monat hyper huge subscription richtig feifett iq plus plus plus
ja also habe ich ganz habe ich gar nicht gesehen dass da bluetooth dabei ist ja also bluetooth ist
von der entfernung noch schlechter zumal es sich hier um low energy bluetooth handelt da weiß
ich nicht wie weit wie weit geht low energy bluetooth fünf meter oder so der lax dange
der lange lax ist auch am start also ja also bluetooth low energy ist die mit abstand kürzeste
variante verbrauch aber auch relativ wenig strom low energy bluetooth wifi verbraucht viel strom und
hat eine nicht so krasse reichweite laura hat bis zu zwei kilometer reichweite aber sehr niedrige
datenübertragung ist auch ein bisschen nicht schon nicht so verbreitet laura ist für solche
sensoren eigentlich fast wie gemacht und bei sich wie und sie will es jetzt ein bisschen anders aus
sich und sie sind beide von von der idee her relativ ähnlich die reichweite an sich ist nicht so krass
aber das ist ein mesh netzwerk das heißt jeder kann es mit wifi auch machen aber du hast in der
regel kein mesh punkt irgendwo in der garage oder so hängen das ist standardmäßig schon
mesh technisch aufgebaut jedes gerät was über sich wie und sie wo jetzt an die steckdose anschließt
fungiert als sagen wir mal so eine art repeater oder als note in dem mesh also ich habe zum
beispiel so ich habe hier oben an meinem home automation server habe ich den seawave stick
und in sich b stick beide wohlgemerkt an einer usb verlängerung weil es immer ganz gut ist wenn
die nicht direkt am server durch wegen stör zeug störsignalen was auch immer es funktioniert auf
jeden fall besser wenn du eine irgendwie eins bis zwei meter usb verlängerung nimmst und hängst
die dinger nebenhin also hier oben im server habe ich die sich b und sie wirf sticks ich habe im
haus verteilt überall sie wo im bleib jetzt mal nur bei sie wo ich sie wo steckdosen habe ich
hier steckt ein drüben wohnzimmer hängt eine unten an der eingangstür hängt eine im keller
hängt eine hinten im stall hängt eine so und ich habe hinten am teich im garten habe ich einen
temperatursensor auf dem ich erkenne ich muss gerade mal gucken vielleicht kann ich euch einen
screenshot von zeigen ja ich mache mal kurz den screenshot von paint
das ist der home assistant tab für meinen garten so viel ist da so viel ist da nicht
das ist der home assistant tab für meinen garten da gibt es einmal baum
der ist gar nicht verfügbar schalter strom an und aus im stall oder die temperatur im
teich und der teich ist grad 4,5 grad das war die wassertemperatur im teich so wurde
der baum gefällt nee das ist led beleuchtung die ist gerade einfach nicht angeschlossen so
und die temperatur vom teich ist ein seawave sensor und dieser seawave sensor schickt seine
daten von also über das seawave mesh und der datenweg ist ungefähr ungefähr so der sensor
broadcast das die seawave steckdose im stall empfängt das schickt es weiter die seawave
steckdose an der eingangstür empfängt es schickt es weiter dann landet es bei meiner steckdose
hier oben im ersten stock die schickt es weiter und dann empfängt es mein seawave stick ja
das ist der vorteil bei seawave und zigbee dass die quasi ohne dass du dich wirklich drum
kümmern musst eingebaute mesh funktionalität haben und genau dafür ist mesh gut dass du große
reichweite bekommst ohne dass das protokoll selber zu ultra low power niedrige bandbreite wie laura
sein muss der laura ist ungefähr brief taubengeschwindigkeit zigbee und seawave
so schnell wie 20 brief tauben also das ist für solche sachen wirklich nicht schlecht also
zigbee und seawave sensoren finde ich mir sowas am sinnigsten was ist eigentlich zukunftsfähiger
zigbee oder seawave tja vor ein paar jahren hätte ich gesagt seawave weil auch die geräte
untereinander zumindest ein gewisses maß kompatibel sein müssen aber dadurch dass die ganzen großen
von phillips you angefangen bis show me aquara und zeug dass die mittlerweile alle zigbee sind
ich würde sagen beides ja aber tendenziell vom preis her sind auch die zigbee geräte besser
matter matter sehe ich noch gar nicht so wirklich zumal es ja auch teilweise nicht ganz mir bis
heute nicht ganz klar ist was das ist matter ist das übergeordnete thread ist irgendwie die
kommunikation und matter kann auch zigbee sein was auch immer scheiß drauf ich benutze das was es
gerade gibt und solange das andere nicht irgendwelche wahnsinns vorteile bietet können die mich alle
mal juckt mich nicht so und auch um die andere frage zu beantworten hier ja korrekt das war
die frage auf womit ich das mache oder wo steht es denn wo ist denn die frage dazu radio wo ist
er denn also direkt wie machst du das mit der stromversorgung genau das ist ein ip67 case ich
bin mir gar nicht sicher ob ich davon irgendwann mal ein foto gepostet habe auf twitter das ist
ein ip67 case und da drinnen ist ein seawave sensor mit einem ds so heißen die dinger so die
s 20 temperature temperature sensor ds 18 b 20 so rum
doch genau nein hier so ein ding hängt bei mir im fischteich was ist fischteich könnte ja
explibische teich sein bei mir ist ein fischteich so so ein sensor hängt dann im fischteich drin
angeschlossen einem seawave sensor und das seawave sensor funkt das seawave sensor selbst steckt
noch mal in dem ip67 case damit es auch schön wasserdicht ist und der funkt dann da vor sich
hin so so habe ich das gemacht genau ja ok cool video weiter contact sensor and the joelink
outdoor contact sensor but the vast majority of people watching this video should just
get the akara heißt das ach joelink habe ich schon nie gehört ring ring kommt mir nicht
ins haus ganzer proprietärer krept da und hier sind zwei kleine ja oder ist günstig
das ding kostet noch nicht mal sonderlich viel es kostet wie sieben euro oder so einen
sensor sogar sogar ok mittlerweile wahrscheinlich teurer akwara door sensor ja gut die china
chinesen auf amazon ist viel zu teuer guck mal aliexpress gleich ali aliexpress komm
her schauen wir mal nein nein nein nein akwara door sensor ja so vier stück 40 euro es
ist teurer geworden es ist teurer geworden auf jeden fall und das ist auch gar nicht
der richtige sensor das sieht schon besser aus ok was habe ich da standardmäßig ausgewählt
517 was sind das wie viele sind das 10 stück 10 euro das stück zoll musste mich bezahlen
die sind die sind die sind schlau was das angeht die verschicken das einfach nach spanien
oder niederlande und dann ist es eine sendung innerhalb von ach so ja doch du musst das theoretisch
schon bezahlen aber du musst nicht angst haben dass man zoll landet alternativ die wie
gesagt die verschicken das e über spanien oder niederlande und dann ist es eine sendung
von eu nach eu und dann hat es juckt es den zoll eh nicht mehr kann auch sein dass mittlerweile
belgien ist ja muss man muss man nach dem günstigsten angebot gucken aber die kann
man empfehlen die gibt es die gibt es wenn ich jetzt gerade aber im angebot definitiv
unter 10 euro das stück ich habe meins irgendwie für 6 7 euro gekauft bengut ist auch ist auch
ganz gut seide dafür diese dinger zu finden ich weiß immer noch nicht wer auf die idee
gekommen ist die seite bengut zu nennen aber so ist es halt aquara door sensor das ist
noch teurer warum ist es denn da so teuer was hältst du von dem ikea zigbee staff kann
man ohne probleme ohne bedenken denken verwenden ja egal wieviel sind das pieces 6 pieces lieferung
von china von china nach germany 11 märz kommt es an ok dauert ein bisschen ja aber die die
sind deutlich günstiger als siebuff sachen deswegen würde ich das wahrscheinlich darauf
setzen wenn ich mir heute da was neues kaufen würde so jetzt müssen wir erstmal angucken
warum ich habe wieder das ihr habt mich wieder nicht daran erinnert dass ich was trinken
soll leute ich muss mehr trinken wenn ich striehme das kriege ich trockenen hals
aber die batterie ohne scheiß ich habe das ding ja auch schon eine weile die batterie
die verliert irgendwie keine keine keine keine spanung also die daran messen ja immer wie voll
die batterie ist der batteriestand ist immer irgendwie noch 98 prozent obwohl das ding
hier schon halbes jahr rumhängt ja ja echt so alter feifett feifett test der das fünf
monate fünf monate hat er das laufen lassen
ja gut weifai weifai ist auch müll dafür
ja ich habe selbst seawave sensor i got some cheap seawave sensor from aliexpress
and they last till today only at the entrance store i had to switch batteries ich habe die
dinger hier seawave seawave neo irgendwas door sensor da hatte ich mir mal irgendwie
ein 20er pack bei aliexpress gekauft von diesen billig dingern hier und die heiß die haben
auch ewig gehalten
weil einer auf englisch gefragt hat siehst du es doch im chat
weil das ding nicht bei jedem open close reported ist es natürlich müll das ist gut das ist
gut ist da eigentlich ist da ist da ist da mein seawave sensor den ich habe auch dabei
sieht nicht so aus ne
ja ich habe den celli aber noch nicht überall da wo ich gerne wo ich ihn gerne hätte weil
ich trau mich nicht den kram selbst einzubauen dazu zu low iq für
der chat fragt wenn du also in russisch fragst bekommst du ja frag mal in russisch
nein nein ich hole mir garantiert keine aquara hab ich hab einen kombi ein kombi stick
und sich b2 mq tt in homos ist ent and to or g2 h camera hubs which open up every other
compatibility that you can think of including home kit google assistant and of course amazon
echo and that brings me to the fifth reason to go with the accara sensors and that's price
the accara contact sensor is normally priced at eighteen dollars and it can frequently
be found on sale for a few oder man kauft zwar ali express und bekommst vor unter zehn
euro was was das sag ichs eben auf russisch gefragt hat bedeutet übersetzt max warum bist
du so fünfköpfig
wie realisierst du die notifications über telegramm ne ich hab kein telegramm also push
notifications ich hab ja keine push notifications aber wie gesagt ich hab diesen klingel anruf
aber ich hab mal ein bisschen experimentiert und dann habe ich es über pushover gemacht
oder was pushover was muss man einmal muss man einmal bezahlen pro device aber dann funktioniert
es
akwara kaufen alles klar
die home assistant companion app funktioniert nur bedingt mit mit notifications wenn du
außerhalb des hauses bist oder das ist jetzt so eine so eine offene frage weil innerhalb
vom wlan und inne da wo der home assistant sauber steht ok aber wenn ich außerhalb bin
dann müsste das da brauche ich dann einen ein home assistant cloud aber oder sowas
dann würde ich es wahrscheinlich auch da drüber machen
das ding ist halt laura ist für den normalen heim anwender halt so ein richtiges nischen
ding wie gesagt laura ist cool ich hab es geschafft von hier bis zum friedhof zu funken
über laura das ist irgendwie 1,5 bis zwei kilometer weg aber im heimbereich ist das
glaube ich ziemlich nicht schön
ok
Ich mache jetzt ein 10-Minuten-Video auf diesen Kontaktsensoren,
das die Pro und Konz von jedem macht.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, gibt es einfach keinen Grund.
Der Ikara-Sensor ist besser als der Rest
durch einen wesentlichen Margin.
Das ist mein allererster Rekord.
Dieses Video ist nicht von mir aus gesponsert.
Ich habe sogar auf Amazon für den Sensor, den ich in diesem Test benutzt habe,
einen vollen Preis bezahlt.
Das SIG B2MQTT ist das Beste, finde ich auch.
Äh, nee, ich baue nichts von diesem Video,
weil ich habe den Kram ja schon.
Exzellent.
Ja, das ist richtig Pog, das Projekt.
Pogu!
Ich habe Hunger, Leute. Wie lange bin ich denn schon on?
3 Stunden?
Heute ging die Zeit aber schnell rum?
Ja.
Wahnsinn, das habe ich gar nicht gedacht.
Pippo Fett?
Äh, hat...
Ja, es werden mehr Geräte unterstützt.
Und...
Und ich persönlich, kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten?
Ich persönlich finde das Web-Interface
mit der Home Assistant Integration besser.
Also SIG B selbst,
SIG B2MQTT,
wir gucken uns das einfach an.
Home Assistant...
Na, super.
Gibt es irgendwelche...
Mal gucken, ob man hier vielleicht Bilder sieht.
Ja, ja.
Ja.
MQTT, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Ja, das ist das Web-Interface,
was man da bekommt. Finde ich persönlich relativ angenehm.
Du hast nämlich Zugriff komplett auf alles.
Kannst dir alles im Detail angucken.
Ich finde es schöner, als die Home Assistant
Integration selbst. Und die unterstützen
halt mehr Geräte. Und oftmals bei diesen
Geräten auch mehrere...
Äh, wie heißt das?
Bei SIG B Device Modes
oder sowas?
Also bei SIG B
weiß ich nicht, wie es heißt, aber bei SIG B
hast du ja verschiedene Sachen. So ein Gerät
hat ja verschiedene
Nodes intern.
Du hast dann sowas wie Sensor
Open-Close, Batteriestand, Batterie
Low, Temperatur,
Temper-Sensor, was auch immer.
Das musst du alles unterstützen, dass du es eben komplett
einbinden kannst.
Ja, also ich mag das.
Ich finde SIG B
2MQTT ist auch das beste.
Dann gibt es noch das andere, was es noch
gibt, ist hier D-Cons.
Äh...
Dieses Ding
gibt es da noch.
Das ist
von denen, die den Konbi-Stick
herstellen. Das ist auch
ein Web-Interface.
Äh...
Das ist aber hauptsächlich gut
für Lichter.
Ja, das ist hauptsächlich gut, wenn du
Lichter und sowas machen willst.
Die unterstützen
weniger Geräte als SIG B
2MQTT.
Ja...
Man muss immer... Das ist halt die Sache,
wenn man das selbst macht. Man muss sich
ein bisschen schlau machen, was denn für seinen
Anwendungszweck die beste Lösung ist.
Nee, du, danke schön für den Sub.
Ahjaja!
Ahjaja! Ahjaja!
Jetzt wo ich das sehe,
habe ich... Ja, habe ich euch schon
gezeigt, habe ich euch schon gezeigt.
Ich habe euch schon gezeigt, dass ich letztens
auf YouTube einen Web-Comic geguckt
habe, der sich Internet-Explorer
Chan nannt.
YouTube.
What the fuck? Was es nicht
alles gibt.
Ahjaja!
Internet-Explorer
Chan.
Oh man.
Es ist mittlerweile alles
verweebt. Ok, wo wir dabei
sind, ein Video gucken wir noch.
What is Nam? History of Twitch's
Anti-Weep-Emote.
Any numbers?
Every emote has a story.
Some darker than others.
Behind all these emotes is a face,
a personality, a history. Das ist die Modern Warfare
Menümusik im Hintergrund.
Of why it became so popular.
My goal is to hunt down
and talk to as many of
these emotes as I possibly can.
If you
have any knowledge about Twitch
emotes, there are three main extensions
for users to download. The most popular
being Better TTV. Just like Twitch
has their own. Ja, Seffen
Dings TV, oder wie das heißt,
supporte ich nicht.
Die haben noch zu viele Probleme.
Just like Twitch has their own global
emotes, Better TTV has their own as well.
This is why I was so intrigued. This emote
is immensely popular within the Twitch
community, but it's a BTTV
global emote. Of course, I'm talking
about the emote for this episode.
The third most popular emote being
used 1.9 billion times.
Nam was uploaded as a BTTV global
emote on December 12th, 2015.
It makes you wonder what's the story behind
this Twitch emote?
Alter,
macht's doch nicht immer so laut,
Mensch.
Alter, Twitch, Twitch emote memes
sind schon teilweise echt
im Film.
Und was genau? Und was genau
hat das mit Anti-Reap jetzt zu tun?
Gar nichts, außer, dass man das ist,
dass sich Twitch Chat irgendwie gedacht hat,
dafür verwenden wir es jetzt.
Nam hat
immer das gleiche Sinn für Jahre und Jahre.
Weebs,
geh die F*** aus! Ein direkter
Gegner zu denjenigen, die meine Yaya spammen.
Diese zwei Emotes sind die einfachste Art,
eine Erinnerung davon, und das ist schon zu spät.
Das Chat-Rummel wird nonstop
Nam vs. Yaya Spammen für
zumindest 10 Minuten.
Dieses Klick von Pylata
hat definitiv die Popularität
der Emote geholfen.
Okay, warum f**ken wir da immer Weebs?
Was geht denn da jetzt ab?
Was zum Teufel ist da?
da ist das z plus plus was ist das das ist z plus plus in einem und dann
wundert mich jetzt gar nichts mehr was was ist da überhaupt los gerade das ist
das ist für alle hyperaktiven z plus plus programmierer oder was
weaves out spread around twitch like wildfire everyone and their mother was
sing it two songs that also be created about the email dj fortnight gamer twitches nam or die
ich kann das gar nicht lauter machen weil die schreien die das ohr weg
ja gut das war die zeiten woran auch auf twitch war
besides being used to just shit on weaves which is necessary for any healthy chat room
ecosystem nam is also used anytime the country vietnam is mentioned they are obvious
good out of all the uses do you have like a favorite use viet viet nam is probably the one of
the good ones i like nam seven is like pretty cool i think i like that as well sorry for the
traffic i was ja sagen ist das teil was doch ganz lustig ever hear a streamer say the word man
like this traffic nam oh gachi man which is a direct spinoff emote featuring a young billy
herrington in almost the same exact pose as nam this email's only purpose is for when the word
man is set on stream sometimes emotes are just like that there's no story or lore necessary i
find it fascinating that an emote like nam is as successful as it is seven years and there is no
sign of stopping truly the definition of a classic twitch emote it's found its spot and there is
nothing that can replace the energy and face of nam because it's been a while since that he must
been on and i know people still use it there so i think again i go back to it's kind of you know
heartwarming it's pretty cool that people still use it still know about it and we'll use it to me i
just i chuckle it's funny it's cool that people use it but jetzt wissen wir bescheid course i had to
ask the most important question of them all is it in our in or weaves out
oh come on that is that is that retort question he's out bro get the fuck out
oh what jetzt wissen wir bescheid namers jetzt haben wir uns wieder weitergebildet was twitch
chat history angeht hat sie hyper gatschi ich glaube ich geh jetzt was essen ich wollte
nämlich heute eigentlich noch ein video aufnehmen falls ich das nicht schon erwähnt habe
was gibt's lasst mal überlegen was gibt's zu essen ich glaube noch über pleibsel von gestern
was heißen würde lachs und nudeln und china chinesen süß-sauersauce
nam nam nam nam so gibt's irgendjemand den wir hosten können ist mein manager wieder
on und spiel valorant müssen wir gucken wenn wenn wenn ja dann hosten wir ihn nein ist er nicht
sieben days ago hier so wird das aber mit streaming lifestyle nix haben wir sonst irgendjemand am
start der krieger ist on red dead redemption juckt mich aber überhaupt gar nicht heißt
kohios valorant in dem fall juckt mich auch nicht ist dann sonst noch irgendjemand kleines
der es verdient hat dem ich folge zeig mal her
das hier ist doch garantiert chat erklärt mir mal ich spreche es nicht aus das ist doch garantiert
so eine typische twitch chat fangfrage oder dass wenn man das ausspricht dann sagt man was anderes
was eigentlich da steht das ist auch so typischer typischer twitch chat jebait ist es nicht es gibt
wirklich streamer der angelt ihn haben wir schon oft gehostet ist er ist er am start wieder am
start von was macht er denn dinger pysen stells ne mortis was ist das was macht er da was bin
ich sehend open open es kann keine ahnung kenni sagt mir gar nix
jo ich glaube ich haustein jemand ich gehe einfach auf was ist mit dem friseur der ist
ja bestimmt nicht on oder der ist ja nie on drei monate ago und irgendwelche weep games
guckt euch an was war er traf vor drei monaten war er on und was ist hier was ist hier ja ist
hier angesagt weeps in was hat er denn da in der hand was ach das ist der schwanz von der katze
wir sehen uns
nächste mal machen wir proga stells machen wir hier weiter und versuchen das
mal ein bisschen schneller zu machen ich gehe jetzt was essen bis denn zu